pour le live officiel important
la bascule qui part et on a
on a du coup on a du coup qu'est ce
qu'on a à l'écran va revoir regarder en
premier ce qu'on a à l'écran
alors les tournois là c'est pas trop le
tournoi qu'on souhaitait regarder n'est
pas digne quatre cavaliers intéressant
ah ça c'est vraiment intéressant aux
écossaises quatre cavaliers répertoire
facile alors ça les amis pour une
surprise c'est une surprise
j'ai pas du tout la réf
là j'ai vraiment pas du tout la réf
ok c'est réputé pour être absolument
rien pour les blancs alors swan et pau
est malade soit il ya coeur bat qui
éclaire et qui peut nous dire ce qui se
passe
ça c'est vraiment j'ai envie de rester
dessus parce que
je suis intrigué quoi c'est rarissime à
ce niveau de la compétition de voir ça
c'est vraiment très rare
alors soit c'est une prépa et alors là
je suis le plus surpris du monde soit
séné peau qui en gestion qui jouent eux
demain contre fabiano
et qui veut et qui veut assurer le coup
je sais pas aucune idée mais c'est c'est
une énorme surprise bien évidemment
normalement je pense que c'est fou j'ai
quatre maintenant ici
je crois qu'ils aiment bien faire fou g4
ici cd ça va aussi les deux bons
c'est quoi la surprise passée juste
l'ouverture en fait c'est pas une
ouverture qui est réputé pour
pour pouvoir gagner en fait tout
simplement c'est quelque chose qu'on
joue avec les blancs contre 5 pour faire
nul en fait normalement
ça c'est vraiment une énorme surprise
baky qui va peut-être nous éclairer
dessus mais un
joli en face il est de fait si la wii
bah ouais il a pris il a pris le
français
adorent jouer d'un f3 il veut faire nul
du coup
ils jouent ça pour gagner
et c'est pas facile de trouver des idées
ici il y en a quand même
pas s'il ya vraiment moyen de jouer le
lien ici alors déjà pour battre jing
quelqu'un qui joue caruana qui est de
toute façon on a très peu de
bons jours pour 15 à 20 % dans
l'ouverture ouais même pas même plutôt
de 10 entre 17 vrai 10 15 et
ont les idées sur les
lemarchal ou même y avait là tu vient de
m'écrire
regard des signes de faiblesse chesnais
[Rires]
portait pas bien là
non mais
il ya souvent
pour toi il ya une idée quoi il veut il
a une idée dans cette ouverture c'est
sûr
et c'est pas évident que ding
sérieux on va voir on sait pas quoi
on sait jamais
la soif bien par rapport à votre micro
pour que tu sois dans cette ligne alors
c'est la ligne avec food et de il ya
quasiment plus d'idées en fait pour être
mieux
c'est la face ils gardent le pire henri
iv celle là c'est vraiment là facile
quoi d'neuf strophes ou g5 c'est vrai
mais si je suis vraiment répond c'est
vraiment notre répertoire facile on fait
ça en plein dedans mais là c'est
vraiment 100% 100% la facile quoi saviez
pas quel point
il était qualitatif de répertoire facile
en fait toi il est ce répertoire c'est
vraiment le premier répertoire en plus
pour la peine
mon premier un premier entraîneur
m'avait appris ça il m'avait dit bon bah
tu joues
il ya le cavalier qui va se replacer et
ça va être quoi food et 6 la
voir dès que ça se replace j'ai vu il
n'ya pas il n'ya pas longtemps il ya une
exigence qui
est un peu mieux aussi ouais tu peux tu
peux jouer pour un vantard et en plus
c'est une surprise c'est une surprise où
il va pas le jouer cinq fois pendant le
temps doit même améliore son idée
contredit d'alépé est juste magnifique
pour un telle photo na waie aujourd'hui
ce qui est un peu surprenant quand même
c'est que dans les ruines principal
contre digue en général il prend
l'avantagé que ce soit
l'espagnol avec détroit
les antilles marshall en général il
prend toujours on te perds un peu en
fait ça soit pas que tu me regardes trop
vite mais comme ça oui voyez plutôt
enfin comment dire dans l'axé vrai dans
l'axé du micro que oui comme ça qui me
regarde dans laxe
ouais parce qu'on n'a pas notre set-up
habituel avec les deux micros l'un
devant l'autre
qui a un beau ça tape
ah oui c'est vrai j'avais vu ça ouais
avec faisait pareil avec ça revient de
loin qui a annoncé c'est moi qui
ai mais bon à wil normalement une ouais
ouais ok complexe complexe vrai tube on
n'a pas
paru si costaud que l'actuel boss quoi
je mon coeur je souffre de la
comparaison avec le prez
normal oui mais c'est mieux ce set up
que celui avec la mousse sur les 1 oui
c'est juste qu'il faut un peu
wedding qui sait pas quoi faire contre
la facile je pense qu'il va jouer le fou
des sis
à bâle à il comprend que il faut arrêter
le mandarin et par les français on
pourra voir les coûts oui oui alors ding
j'étais quasiment sûr qu'il va faire un
bon candidat
de
[Musique]
l'arrivée juste trois jours avant en
fait ce qui est très bizarre
moi c'est surtout ça qui m'a fait peur
pour lui c'est qu'il est vraiment arrivé
l'adaptation quoi qui doit être très dur
puis le jet lag qu'il a dû se prendre le
jet lag l'adaptation
non mais c'est trop c'est trop court
terme en une semaine par regarder car on
était quelques semaines en espagne comme
ni même si on a quasiment
non ça c'était très étonnant
on regarde pas ali reza ben je sais pas
moi j'étais content va on va on va
tourner mais je suis pas rajouté
intrigué par ce début de partie
personnellement ces gars là ont attribué
par tous il karuk à roanne
on va enfin on fait quoi on tournicote
on se met sur avec le grand échiquier et
ont fait un petit tour ouais on peut se
faire un petit tour ok bon pas celui-là
c'est pas très juste ces quatre
cavaliers g3 bon ça c'est pas le top
népotisme irène ça c'est celle qu'on
vient de voir naka au fantastique ah oui
c'est alors c'est maxime c'est la partie
maxime
caruana de bucarest
donc il rejoue ce dame alors ils jouent
dam des six il avait joué dame 17 je
pense à maxime
il rejoue serait
alors l'espagnol ouverte
c'est bizarre quand même oui ça joue
vite des deux côtés ils connaissent un
ouais c'est surpris que fabiano ils
partent mais bon tu me diras là
aujourd'hui il joue plus pour nul est
assez content je pense
- il élimine un gars qu'on place et a
donc donc l'espagnol ouverte oui ça fait
du sens il sait que
s'il veut jouer
il doit il va devoir prendre des risques
si vous gagnez quoi car au
mic un oublié là il est vraiment must
win et ça fait plus de sens pour lui de
force est dans cette position que pour
richard hier entre n'est pas le moment
là ils connaissent tous les deux
j'imagine que tu connais aussi mais bon
patrick bruel voila voila je me souviens
plus de 300 e mail oui mais c'est sûr
que tu es
obligatoirement regarder il a joué ici
mise à jour plein de fois
donc ça on a vu et firoud radjabov du
coup la dernière qu'on n'est pas on
n'est pas suivi ok ça jaunes italiennes
j'y comprends jamais rien d'acquis
alors les petits coups comme h3
hockey comme je pense que alireza déjà
il joue pour éviter les lignes avec des
5 oui il ya souvent des lignes force et
c'est pour ça qu'ils jouent des âges 3
et que ça rende et la voilà c'est dur à
comprendre
mais toi que vous quand vous analysez
vous comprenez quand même ou des fois
c'est même pour comprendre ça prend du
temps
les italiennes
donc tu sues quoi même même un bas qui
quand ils regardent su même les ordis
tout le monde a un nom dessus parce
qu'en fait tu sais jamais il faut en
quoi je crois un poil 6 un coupé quatre
quoiqu'à atteint coût à 3 fin
mai après ouais c'est si les noirs et je
trois quatre coups précis tu sais pas
comme
contre king zig ça fait quatre ans
qu'ils jouent la même ligne il me la
jouer en
2018 est achevée la même ligne ouais il
m'a joué la même ligne alors j'avais une
petite idée avec habillage cadre pas
joué exactement comme icare ou mais
depuis ce temps la satire band aid
en général c'est plus à la mode les
dessins qu'elle est à 5 c'est quand même
le ca la mode que je vous rajhi après
et le assise dans la silène de radio
hier sata surpris ou pas du tout abbas
était intéressant et avait peut-être pas
nous dire mais je n'ose qu'on a remarqué
après dans l'analyse c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui avaient joué la
même chose qu'eux enfin dominguez des
sceaux avait joué la même chose que
caruana
peut-être qu'il a réfléchi pour se
souvenir de ses analyses ou ce qu'il a
joué ce jeu s'est pas tu verras dur à
dire après ce que j'ai été étonné quand
on analyse a posteriori qu'il ait
réfléchi aussi longtemps est finalement
que ça retombe est vraiment dans l'est
dans la ligne quoi
on est là la wii voilà ça va beaucoup
réfléchir non les italiens de chaque
coup important
je pense qu on reste un peu sur n'est
pas vrai ce que c'est j'ai pas déjà ça
peut jouer vite c'est le cargo il a joué
fou dossier soit évidemment tour un tour
des huit cavaliers d1 a été là où
s'arrête la prépa facile est-ce que ça
serait pas cavalier des
dont la pâle qui a validé un nous on a
plutôt b3 c'est ça que ça serait pas le
dernier coup et voilà la petite la
petite nouveauté
et si et je ne sais pas est ce que ça
peut être
bon il est simple c'est carré bloqué
mais je dois aussi la page
ici penco il a vraiment mal joué
d'ailleurs
aucun moment difficile pour lui sa
complexion
oui non c'est sûr mais justice n'ont pas
forcément échiquier oui mais je vais
revenir soit peut-être qu'en france tout
comme on est plus au courant ah oui
comme on sait qu'ils sont bourrés ou pas
il arrive à beaucoup sur l'échiquier oui
que c'était lui aussi les autres sont
peut-être moins au courant quoi au delà
on était quand même beaucoup plus près
peut-être que tu es français à l'accueil
y est maintenant nous on a perdu contre
lui ah oui c'était qui sera guère à huy
pourtant il est au courant mais
peut-être aussi rigueur et du coup le a
peut-être qui a posé problème un gars
super cool on l'a déjà fait avec moi
c'est bon
toi aussi je sais
mais vous avez gagné d'ailleurs
félicitations ouais ouais c'était cool
on a est maso a pas maso
important la petite nul
ah oui contre entre cornetto pourtant
théoriquement il était bien oui mais
après mon tactique a pas c'est pas
forcément bien passé donc cavalier t on
pas mal
intéressant en tout cas logique tu
défendes qu'ils ont et puis si il a pas
passé beaucoup de temps dessus
pas facile à réagir et c'est final ça
vaut quoi
je me pose toujours la question pour moi
en fait je poserai
ça peut être moins bien des fois au fait
genre qu'il arrive vite en f5 et en fait
ça dépend de compte qui
est aux anges parce que il suffit d'une
erreur blanche et tu as dû ces cinq c4
enfin tu mais bon au
contre quelqu'un qui va jouer que les
meilleurs coups ça peut s'appeler ouais
ça parce que
c'est pour ça que c'est pas si mal de la
part de mes potes et arlequin risque
normalement avec les blancs
enfin ça doit dépendre de 3,4 courant
fêtera d'arifat agissent donc sarenza
hyper intéressant en fait
et
on va voir cette finale
j'avais essayé de la faire marcher pour
les bleus à un moment mais je n'ai pas
vraiment trouvé
après c'est vraiment dans ton style à
thouars dans cette rue clac avec les
fous de couleurs en coulant mais je n'ai
pas donné les fous oui mais bon tu vas
peut-être le récup
mais bon tu veux la voir quand même pas
pour lui la pâte est pas contente ouais
tu as
[Rires]
évolué oui déjà ramène le 40e 5 après on
verra ça n'était vraiment pas donné les
fous
tu vois ici on sait jamais par exemple
si tu regarde par exemple si ce qui a
valu à 3,5 a joué 7 4
est ce que tu as pu suivre en direct la
rencontre de vlad huys et planus
métis alors que quand même bon bah non
mais là je vais pouvoir
[Musique]
je vais être obligée d'aller voir ça ah
c'était magnifique
maxime était très heureux il a joué sans
grève saint chrême d'accord m6 il est
prêt m pouvant plus si les prêts ça va
être
si jamais la piste et qui connaît pas ce
que c'est risqué comme coup bah c'est
pas mal il se fait lacazette 6 pour
l'euro oui mais après un coup comme f4
aurait pu marcher pour essayer de 20
dans messi joue et 5 ceux qui
connaissent
la valeur perd 4 tempo away
oui bon ça c'est que
il a toujours su
mais bon oui et non bajaj au rack'am
inquiet blanc mais bon ça va être nul
quoi juste quand même pas très agréable
il n'y a pas de tout
ça peut être un peu chiant ouvrir et
j'en ai trop cru que m qui connait tous
en fait ces icônes et où et quand même
toi pov'
j'aime bien les mettre en grande kawaii
se lève en plus laïque colonisation
ouais et puis là
là il va pas faire n'importe quoi pour
pour gagner il ya non non non non la
liane il est tranquille
quand tu vois même la petite turbine est
que le trou numéro un c'est g3 tu
comprends que j'ai 3g dos à dos oui oui
c'est sûr mais bon ouais on remarque
donc voilà je vais quand même y croire
elle va d'ailleurs il connaît
il ya encore des petites machines pour
la dragée haute
à raison oui oui mais oui vous faudra
jouer un petit peu pas compté les îlots
dont 24 comment on va remettre un vrai
relais 3 m maintenant je pense qu'il va
pas jouer le jeu
ouais
mais bon du coup de froid j'ai droit à
trois études parce que roissy ce fou 17
tu tape un peu ses six
en rester qu'un
alors il faut être très bien enfin s'il
a deux trois coups très précis encore ça
mais les way c'est obligé qui
connaissent un peu plus loin mais bon ça
même à jouer avec les blancs tu veux
dire à un niveau tu es un amateur
jusqu'à 2000 2100 imagine tu as avec les
blancs tu connais bien te trompes toi
beaucoup jusqu'à 2006 tu connais ça avec
les blondes loin tu peux tu peux faire
mal non ouais
enfin c'est difficile d'avoir un petit
avantage comme ça dans les ouvertures en
réalité c'est pas c'est pas commun quoi
mais là ouais tu vois il va pas prendre
en f&a ya pas photo
voilà les deux connaissent encore un
c'est évident
sûrement être à base de h 5 h quatre
mots ils nous disent ding a déjà eu la
même position 1
il connaît beaucoup trop bien
du coup c'est bizarre s'il avait
plusieurs fois cette position faire que
niveau c'est peut-être bête malade ouais
ou peut-être problèmes de dernière
minute
lembeye quoi ils ont plombé
la jav est pas là rêve s'il a eu
plusieurs partis
comme sade
pas très normal les dix neuf sessions
ding 2019
ladd qui a toujours sur sat est déjà
arrivé toit sans rentrer dans le secret
des dieux d'avoir un maxime qui disent
une heure avant la partie [ __ ] j'ai
mal à l'estomac où tu vois je sais pas
j'ai un problème ce sont les dernières
deux minutes et une ok tu joues ça et tu
rentres à touba où et des fois ils
prennent 7
arrive je peux avoir un problème aussi
des fois tu as pas le temps de tout
vérifier comme tu
ouest juste d'un coup tu parles moi à
moins que il est encore une poussette en
fait oui à moins qu'ils aient vu la
partie qui est une idée qui a eu une
idée qui veut la loi qui veut quand même
la teste oui niveau des 3 alors je
pensais qu'avec un fou 17
pour des stades pour prendre un peu les
cases pour bien mettre sur les cases
blanches
c'était mieux parce que là j'ai peur
qu'un tour f 1 8 3 jets d'eau tour 6 par
exemple
j'ai peur qu'un truc comme ça et très
vite tu peux pas soit tu
si tu gagnes pas la cause ouais tu peux
peut-être mais
ouais tu donnes pas que je la sais je la
sens pas trop trop mais ok
c'est toujours pareil si l'on analysé
longtemps avec l'ordi à des idées que
visuellement si ça passe pas et après
ça va pas être la partie la plus fun à
suivre pas se mentir non mais bon c'est
la facile à dire mais c'est bel est
importante on
a du coup on peut retour on est
peut-être avoir la caresse que j'allais
dire de toute façon va beaucoup avoir
envie de tourner entre naka n est pas
forcément
beaucoup trop complexe
la lys ajout est ce qu est ce que tu as
être calmes la
réfléchi côté
non non ça se sent gj tout les cas main
de toute façon
ça calcule c'est qu'alors les gens qui
pensaient dans le chat que kg 3 à une
gaffe parce que l'ordi mes erreurs c'est
juste qu'il a analysé ce coup là avec
une turbine beaucoup plus forte que la
vôtre parce que c'est sur ces prépas il
a dépensé 3 30 pour vous est ce que tu
veux que je regarde en live
chef de la haye mais d'eptica crocs
quand même est ce qu'il a gagné la coupe
de france nouvelle chef aujourd'hui
d'y jouer quoi
jouer la coupe de france finale de la
coupe de france on leur laisse on la
joue pas avec mais je
vivrai pas de titres possibles pour
notre mvl chess et où on peut voir la
partie
maxime est comme il est là il peut nous
en fait oui est-ce que son équipe est ce
qu'il a gagné puisque le champion riche
que lui il a gagné
mais du coup il alors du coup je prends
en plus j'ai déjà connectés à internet
d'ici et où donc toujours dans les votes
tattoo
ouais ouais je l'aï derrière on va te
l'a trouvée d'être là nintendo aussi si
tu veux faire en mario
mais ce que maxime nous donne tout est
possible méthodes nous faisons résultat
c'est pas possible
c'est pas possible maxime qui nous donne
pas les réponses
il va jamais nous répondre en fait c'est
terrible
il a fait nul je suis pas prêt on voit
on via ya pas mal de mes chats dans le
chat on peut rater
ok ils ont gagné 2-0 et il a fait nul si
je comprends bien mais bon il met des
émeutes et où il a décidé de nous faire
chier en fait c'est pas possible pas qui
il a mis lui même
il est beau satc c'est peut-être le plus
belle et vote de tous le mv l'imposteur
il est très réussie frau
ouais tu peut débrancher n'importe quoi
ici
pourquoi
tu peux absolument tout retiré
ayana il ya le mode lan cros et ludwig
qui a mis le mode lent mais le dès qu'il
est vraiment parti c'est vraiment
extraordinaire il va vraiment écrit
après déjà avant la partie de karwan
elle m'a dit je passerai pas trop et
après il m'a dit quand vous faites les
petit récap écrit moi que je puisse que
je puisse les récupérer
il ne passe vraiment plus
ouais en fait à la logique dès que tu
perds c'est fini en fait
car ou keithley moi je vais faire un
petit passage longue bas qui allume gaz
naturel prépa écart ou à chaque fois
alors bon évidemment je vais jouer je
vais pas
je vais mettre juste à la la
laissant l'asb aquifère faire son boulot
il envoie là-bas qu'il envoie
à tout moment sans voyant civilisation a
pendant la partie bas qui
en fait ça va pas du tout fait la turbie
elle en fait un malaise ont pas du tout
en fait ça avec le hockey est
intéressant hyper intéressant ça on peut
faire sans turbine l'otan de
tu comprends ce qui se passe ici
est ce qui va pas jouer pour grand roc
comme auch à auckland contre maxime un
oui je me rappelle jouer du geste d'amos
g5y peut même laisser le roi au centre
pour l'instant parce que la cie va pour
duty rock alors souvent on va on va
jouer pour flouer 3 donc soit cavaliers
c4 foudroie
cavaliers info le droit et on va avoir
du tour à deux aussi pour recycler la
tour là-bas mais je me demande s'il va
pas jouer plus tôt pour nom
champlain n'est perdu dans cette partie
ouais mais c'était compliqué oui ça
donne des partis un peu tes courses de
fond oui oui bien sûr et un garçon la
mort il n'est pas là pour faire pour ses
rétros le job weir a dit oui là pour
s'amuser aussi mais bon essayer de
gagner deux parties
mais bon chantier avec un perdu quoi
normal oui oui non c'était pas une
surprise non plus et on me dit que ça a
dévié chesnais pudding mais bon ça a
dévié de sa partie il va faire un geste
en cash 4 vite pour essayer mais quand
même
ça doit se tenir quand même
parti elle sans compliquer quand même
annoncé
sur l'ordi on va un tout rachat non
skate après
pas même pas en parler
ouais c'est gros poisson c'est dur à
dire ben là c'est que du calcul non mais
c'est pas ouais c'est pas si
si neil silhouette
dans des malades qui meurent et écrit
est-ce qu'il va passer nous voir
c'est nous voir un peu plus tard vlad
après quatre nuls et
il m'a dit je dois passer en ville
vraiment très important
n'est pudding et dans les cars ouanna
qui en aucun cas rouennais qui s'est
pris le cavalier g3 la grosse prépa di
caro
complexe un pur
pour famille
ouais je te laisse je laisse les coûts
là bas qu'ici tu veux de toute façon on
est on est sur l'échiquier
caruana seul assis à sa table
et oui en plus hikaru il peut se
replacer dans le tournoi et il peut
prendre un point toafa be j'ai entendu
dire qu'il sait n'est pas trop les deux
mais tu vois j'étais dgd tout à l'heure
que c'était impressionnant voilà savard
est pas elle est juste impressionnant
c'est le seul qui a posé des problèmes à
une épaule
oui wind carlson et n'a pas posé un
problème dans le match oui oui il n'a
pas eu besoin mais n'avait pas eu besoin
mais il n'en a pas posé là il était le
premier à avoir posé votre parti on voit
que
c'est la crise qui a fait ces prépas des
carreaux
clairement après il a les moyens
financiers aux siens hikaru on n'a pas
entendu parler non plus qu'il a eu accès
à vraiment super ordi ça peut être aussi
le lot possible
après il ya une autre posséder une
troisième possibilité c'est que tu
travailles pour lui en fait
[Rires]
pas de nom alors c'est qu'à cros qui
bossent pour lui ça c'est possible big
blue
reef plutôt logique d'ailleurs je ne
viens plus voir le tournoi je n'ai pas
le temps oui bien sûr j'ai entendu dire
qu'après tous ces stages d'entraînement
un autre homme
c'était devenu un autre homme ou de vie
mais du coup en jouant à ce niveau-là
hikaru il aurait une petite chance
contre carlson d'après toi ou pas du
tout pas du tout
trop d'historique
théorique vraiment catastrophique
et carlson c'est aussi le mieux préparé
afin non évidemment mieux préparés du
monde
tout l'investissement c'est plus qu'un
million et demi pas sur deux ans comme
on est paumé paumé maman mais sur les
dix dernières années s'est constamment
entraîneur donc
donc ouais mais alors voilà c'est pas
souvent heureux qu'ils n'avaient pas
bien dans ce cas qu'il est surpris déjà
dans un premier temps
un haka c'est vraiment un joueur très
très impressionnant quand même surtout
qui c'est qui est plus vraiment joueurs
professionnels enfin il a plus été
pendant quelques années elle a ici est
remis sur sur les trois quatre derniers
mois mais c'est impressionnant d'être
venus aussi vite à niveau 1
aux prix
des trois esi est contraint à paris nwè
ah oui et contre paris incroyable
c'était le destin
mais par contre entre autres
et
ça va payer dans les title bas qui en
fait ça serait trop tomber dessus cette
histoire
on entend parfois pas très un bâti mais
c'est quand il est sur l'ordi là bas
c'est normal c'est parce qu'il est il en
train d'analyser
gens désespèrent caritatif qui financent
ces frais patrick c'est pas possible pas
pu suivre ce truc là ça je vais aux
particuliers le twitter de aux réserves
non c'était particulier
si dans un monde humaniste n'existe pas
on parlerait beaucoup plus dit qu'avant
en général c'est papa complètement faut
à mon avis
pas que
un bain tous les joueurs
entre la place numéro deux et dix on va
dire la fin du monde des champions du
monde différent occasion tous les
raisons au moins tous les quatre oui il
y aurait une défense bien il n'y aurait
pas de champion la com com juste trop
trop impressionnant ma news est devenu
numéro un mondial en djing
way où il venait d'être numéro un
mondial
jing c'était 2009 ouais 2009 feraient
donc cédé trois fois d'arrêter de jouer
aux échecs de
13 ans c'est moi je faisais encore plus
plus impressionnant kasparov perso mais
bon là ça semblait devenir le même genre
ouais mais
[Musique]
bon c'était fort aussi restée fin vous
avez quand même ok après karpov eu un
nom de crown oui non c'était quand même
des mais bon il est quand même vrai mais
bon il est de ce calibre-là ah oui c'est
le
forez qui gagne encore 2 matchs de
championnat du monde pour vraiment by
peu la
bastille à dire soyez radar il n'ya pas
d'ali reza ou de prague ananda ou de
quelqu'un mais vraiment incroyable c'est
pas impossible vu l'investissement
personnel
cali raisin on l'avait vu très fort
c'est la première fois qu'on le voit
baisser de niveau entre deux de
compétition la grande type
un petit peu fatigué
quelque chose qui va pas non la prépare
en tout cas pas forcément les ouvertures
mais il veut globale être quelques très
bonnes idées
mais il a jamais alors c'est quelqu'un
qui réfléchit c'est quand même longtemps
sur les coups durs ouais mais là c'est
là c'est trop là c'est trop c'est trop
non mais là des fois il fait un coup
l'autre répondent coup mail et il
reprend encore 15 20 minutes
après l'essai vrai que c'est la première
fois qu'il fait pas d'eux
entre chaque tournoi et je jouais mieux
c'est ça va être
pareil ou mieux rêve tous les six mois
il y avait vraiment un gap
impressionnant dans ces
îles attention qu'il a même régressé
pour la première fois non mais régressé
non mais je veux dire par là
d'habitude c'est
la partie bavure la dernière à la partie
contre maxime witt même si ok on a un
grand maxime la dernière partie qui
reste
c'était quand même pas forcé de sa part
de
namas quizy roi il a voulu jouer le gain
à fond là bas parce que ces derniers
sont en préparation il a voulu en mettre
beaucoup bon et il voulait peut-être se
tester et c'est même et
après il faut dire
il a commencé avec trois fois les noirs
pas facile quand même quand tu joues
caruana c'est aussi pas les mêmes que
dans les tournois normaux non mais le
niveau de jeu est pas là c'est papa
c'est pas pareil c'est pas le même
caruana ce n'est pas le même nez pour
des sites manque il lui a manqué cette
victoire contre icaew en fait
non c'est vrai mais celle contre
rapporte la finale c'était
ouais
il n'a pas eu vraiment ses positions
même content car aux
noms mais je pense qu'ils ont vraiment
commencé à comprendre comment jouer
contre lui et il le prive
de ses positions mais bon c'est sympa
c'est passager
mais bon ces temps de se réadapter aussi
pour les échecs si
quelques tournois où j'ai moins bien
aussi où il est et que tu commences à
gagner ta la réussite qui revient hanter
les coups qu'ils reviennent se joue vite
que clic bien
la partie qu'il a gagné contre caruana
elle lui fait un bien énorme
le tour prend 3,2 caruana
par exemple ou la tour de radio de
rapports way
et sa chance ou immédiatement et away et
puis sa dernière journée absolument
incroyable demain son jeu mais s'est
amenée par bah oui par 2 3 1 pour de
circonstance en fait et après les mecs
qui ont plus peur de jouer contre lui de
même en norvège il a pas de la sphère
bon tournoi mais mon père de recours
oui oui mais après c'est un engrenage et
la haye l'iresa c'est vrai qu'il a été
dans un engrenage difficile dès le début
du tournoi mais
déjà il a été radié il a fait une très
bonne partie est contre lui oui oui oui
il faut le dire aussi
excellente partie d'alireza mais aussi
attendait peut-être pas
après après il ya le côté gestion est ce
que tu vois enfin on voit bien comment
on fait maxime tu vois et ça lui réussit
plutôt bien maxi je pense qu'on fera dit
la position qui avait détruit prend la
cloche qui rentre dans la chambre
d'hôtel deux heures de jeu avec
baignoire merci merci monsieur revoir tu
vois ça ils utilisent ces promeneurs on
voit que ça prend énormément via les
réseaux rien que de changer d'ouverture
tout c'est ça tu vois tu change tout le
temps à une prépa qui a il lui a manqué
l'énergie après peut-être ou peut-être
qu'il va s'en rendre compte ou celle des
tournois vraiment
continue à jouer tempo et qui en bon il
ya beaucoup de 0-0 comme d'habitude dans
les ouvertures
mais
mais à l'air quand même plus agréable
pour les blancs salle elie
ouais là temps j'ai juste passé pendant
que tu as tu j'attendais juste rejeté un
oeil furtif
bon là cette fois ci là ça paraît simple
et des
dons qu'il avait pas vraiment d'idée
yann peut-être avoir une décision de
dernière minute
est donc caruana
il ya écrit cripple peines qui demandent
pourquoi il sort des grosses peuvent pas
au début et - là
en fait c'est juste que bien tombé au
début oui oui et puis peut-être qu'il ya
plus lénifiants yassa il est bien tombé
à peut-être le fait qu'il est plus
l'énergie de nom mais les matins leur
dit de haut et sont fous ces quatre
dépôts
mais oui mais il n'a pas la suite et
ouais ça c'était bizarre ouais c'est
intéressant mais
bah oui un leader enfin tu as trop dur
ben ouais tu si tu joues alors on va
voir s'il rejoue un âge d'or peut-être
que sur quatre salines prostate
qui on voit qu'avec les blancs et jaunes
une fois des cats une fois aux quatre
une fois
c'est dur à tout gérer on sait rien que
quand tu joues la même chose même comme
maxi ou comme moi quand je l'entends
dire bonjour et qu'une nouvelle une
ouverture principal en tout cas c'est
dur de
tout avoir et ça prend déjà plusieurs
heures dans la journée
tous les matins rechanger mais durant
sans ça c'est pour ça le choix de la
partie compte qu il affirma parti compte
radjabov delajoux en plus à fond c'est
qu'en plus il s'inflige entre guillemets
des parties très longue
ouais c'est qu'ils pourraient dire ok
j'ai un répertoire plus largement et tu
as un peu comme dépôts qui joue quand
même allez quoi mais je peux le temps
régie alors n'est pas comme chico bah
ouais c'est pour ça ça ne dérange pas
aujourd'hui ouais c'est ça le hockey il
prend il a une chance il va l'apprendre
sinon bah là il va se reposer demain à
une époque il joue à l'économie ils
économisent
et alireza dont il a toujours joué ça a
été toujours un des plus grands
combattants aux fêtes
dès le début mais moi il faut peut-être
aussi apprendre garder ce brillant mais
il faut aussi ou peut-être pas du tout
peut-être il a juste pas eu de chance
possible réussite au bon comme ça et
enchaîner et oui oui bien sûr en fait on
voudrait savoir banon mais la réussite
ça joue beaucoup la réussite c'est la
chance en fait
la maîtrise
mais là c'est sûr que comme ça fait
longtemps qu'il n'a pas gagné une partie
en plus de ce mode
web où il a été vraiment malchanceux
pour le coin là il n'a pas être à
bucarest n'a vraiment pas eu vol oui
mais quand je joue comme ça que tu as
pas de chance pas de chance pour
adversaires les styles combat
fantastique 1
ouais enfin ben jawad après peur de
hadji diouf dit rabbin jouer
oui depuis 20 parties alors que là tu
joues dépôt de bois où tu joues caruana
demain
mais ils gagnent à fond et
donc bon babel près pain de dix cars ou
même si ça peut faire nul
[Musique]
dans les montagnes est pas moi je
regarde la région tentant quand même
très bien saisie à quelques personnes
dans le chat un peu mou de l'oreille
ah bah oui mais important être un peu
mou de l'oreille
un peu mou de la faille choix que ces
différents noms
et d'amd devraient jouer puisque je
quatre voies pour favy va clairement à
un casse et aux cadres en cas de seul
coup pourtant à 4 à 8 soit à cech juste
toi tu sais quoi mais en hockey ce qui
est clair en regardant quand même les
lignes c'est que c'est très intéressant
de la part d' car ou est
il va falloir un grand fabi pour
ce qu'est ce qu'on se dit c'est sympa
sicav ou gagne parce que ça fait une
course à trois où est ce qu'on se dit ça
éloigne trône et pau on en veut car aux
gay games et non moi je pense aussi ce
serait beau il renie pas ce qu'ils
méritent car enfin il reviendrait ou
s'il gagne et c'est dommage qu'il ait
pas battu les pots en fait ça ça aurait
été mieux à s'arrêter de tard parce
qu'en plus c'était vraiment dans le dans
l'histoire de la partie live elle a
gagné de belles régnait là
et il était il était pas bien après
après cette partie contre contenu pour
il a peut-être compris que oui il a
compris qu'il a laissé passer une grosse
chance non il a compris que c'est
peut-être la partie qui va qui valait
oui l'écouté oui oui value écoutez le
le titre enfin le bonheur c'est utile de
sa vidéo sur ce riz cap c'était à une
disgrâce tu ouais enfin sur twitter j'ai
vu qu'il y avait ça c'est la première
fois mais ouais parce qu'il a tout fait
et qu'il méritait bon des fois tu
mérites pas ah bon c'est pas grave la de
dommages et surtout qu'il sera iv et vi
en fait ce serait à égalité avec non il
serait pas égalité il aurait un demi
point de plus il serait à 4 ea et n'est
pas cinq ans ils seraient plus qu'à un
point il ne serait qu'à un point
j'ai peur que il lâche ses gagne pas
celle là aussi
en ce qui aurait conduit hikaru qu'on
lui jouera plus la première place parce
que là c'est sa dernière chance
quatre ennemis et la cure in mid bref
c'est comme la dernière fois qu on ice
et chirurgical c'est spectaculaire au
fait et il fait exactement quand la
dernière fois quand il est vraiment
devant la is mais quand même en mode
gestionnaire mais je joue pas pour faire
du lys remettant risques non il se
dépense qui gère gère gérer affirme
qu'il est le bon je suis peut se dire
ouais bah écoutes je vais encore
reprendre un de mes points sur fabi
ouais voilà jouer tranquille où
il est en départage il est pas mal aussi
il est grand rapids l'idylle est bon
aller pendant deux
ans puis là demain en plus il va être en
a une partie très importante contre
contre favy et c'est vrai que c'est pas
idiot de jouer aux 8 de moss et ouais
c'est vraiment pas idiot de jouer une
araignée aujourd'hui le mot c'est claude
donc tu dormais un machin tu dit fabien
il va s'épuiser contre saint affrique à
roue et moi je viens demain bien préparé
je fais ma petite niche car mon demi
point d'avancé à j'envoie petrov de mots
je suis tranquille après pure web
donc il nous faut en fait il nous faut
une victoire di caro aujourd'hui une
victoire de favidema en fait ça ce
serait l'idéal
ça remettrait à trois une course à trois
est ce qu'on regarde est-ce qu'on
mettrait pas vite fait la partie
d'alireza quand même une idée baky
qu'est ça c'est les parties
karlsson background
car il y en a eu
mais des anciennes on retombe il a joué
pour petit rock en fait il n'a pas joué
comme shankland pour le baroque
d'ailleurs un peu bizarre à est-ce qu'on
peut remettre après le tir rock
un peu bizarre d'
pas sûr que qui est pas de judas
moussette g5 vite
il a l'air de connaître hadji quand même
un iphone ou tempo
là donc on a souvent du tour à deux là
pour
tenir f2 on a souvent dû on aime bien en
général je me fous et 3 aussi
après soir prend reprendre de la tour
faut il faut trouver un moyen de voyager
3 aussi pour prendre la case du cavalier
f4 faut pas que les noirs puisse jouer
cavalier f4 dans de bonnes conditions
lors du g3 âgés de 15 et les h2k alors
là je pense qu'il ya g3 salaire trop
dangereux trop gêné c'est trop vite
ouais parce qu'avec la diago latu
peut-être même dame g6 d'ailleurs tape
g3 sirois jets d'eau peut-être tout
reprend 3
ok
donc c'est un peu
un peu vite mais après un fou et 3 par
exemple après un cafouillage 5 fu et 3
par exemple prise si tu prends du
cavalier il ya souvent cavalier f4 là ça
va être dur de jouer
c'est plutôt tout reprend mais on est
toujours au tempo près attention c'est
des fois tu as du tessin qui est sûre
cavalli f4 peut-être essayer de jouer
hkd là comme lecavalier 3 il est bien
tenue tu vois tu peux avoir du petit
temps ou à la place de 2 et 3 mai
toujours au tempo parce qu'il ya
toujours des dessins qu'avoir du dam
jesse savoir we say say say des plans
mais ça marche ça marche parce que ça
marche et donc des fois quand on est
tranquille dont je vous ai 3 pour [ __ ]
3,33 aussi mais on va être ça va être
plus difficilement mieux pour les blancs
quand on va jouer on va réussir à jouer
des quatre un moment mais on n'a plus un
tel avantage de structurer les
structures sont quasiment symétrique
même même qu'elle est même complètement
en fait t'as un tout petit peu un tout
petit avancent normalement tu réussis à
jouer des quatre mais c'est trop et
c'est pas assez quattro léger mais par
contre si tu joues pas pour les fous ou
trois apprête à des risques d'attaqué
mairie avec 4 tu as montré qu'ils
avaient les f4 dams et si ça arrive vite
donc si je dis pas de bêtises c'est
souvent
il ya cavaliers h2o si l'on joué mais
bon sur l'échiquier c'est pas bon et ça
lui avait porté un coup facile
trop compliqué pour nous ça
mais bon il faut qu'ils gagnent
aujourd'hui ali reza et non mais j'ai
joué ça ouvre aussi aux grandes chasses
tours paris contre magnus en 2000
18 je dirais ou 2017 je sais plus
exactement
et tu arrives à cul non j'avais perdu
mais il avait fait une part il avait
joué juste tous les meilleurs coups et
c'était vraiment très dur avec une
minute à la pendue mais il a vraiment
tout trouver tous les bons coups il
avait fait une partie magnifique
insupportable ouais j'ai eu plusieurs
fois ce genre de position avec les noirs
avec le f points 6 contre car yakine
contre un joueur comme ça qu'elle ça
marche bien au général parce que c'est
mieux pour les blancs mais il faut être
juste trop chirurgicale et maxime ne les
joue très bien aussi
c'est en a très peu fait deux trois
joueurs comme ça qu'ils peuvent tout
bois francs qui joue pas mal aussi ses
structures
et blanc avec baignoire avec les noirs
bas par exemple ça ressemble aux parties
de double contre max quasi reste que
j'avais moi-même maximy les a pas
toujours et oui c'est ce que je vais
dire d'où part il faut bien c'est la
russie c'est pas qu'il ait joué on sait
que c'est plus facile avec le nombre
inouï cette cité pas absolument porter
avec les blancs c'est mais maxime et les
joues bien plutôt les jouets bien
d'ailleurs plutôt long des joues plus
ça et ça fait un moment qu'on a pas vu
sur l'italienne maxime quand même de
temps en temps et en
mai puis sans surprise
c'est beau aussi à l'italienne mais bon
après il est très à l'aise sur les bas
rhinoises maximum
d'ailleurs je suis bien
dépôt il a fait pareil
parce qu'on disait il ya que maxime qui
la joue et puis tout n'est pas aussi
chaud qu'ils ont tous commencé à jouer
autant la chine autant la finale que oui
que le
que milieu de jeunes ou maxime agueh une
belle partie contre wesley
à lui caresse away non en norvège là
ça fait un peu n'importe quoi ou wesley
il avait il a complètement raté un coup
moi j'ai plus large il a raté mais les
bons maxime a gagné c'est le plus
important il faut oui
c'est le plus important et cette pétrole
afin qu'il vient vraiment une arme du
trait principal contre 4 et je me
demande pourquoi né pas même plus jouer
la petrov parce qu'en fait c'est
tu peux pas gagner une partie en fait on
joue à 2658 moi je vois que des poèmes
la joue là petrov
insidieux il va évoluer pour faire 10
nuls en fait parce que je n'ai même pas
d'efforts à faire pour essayer de
pousser un petit peu alors pour vraiment
alors que c'est une ouverture bien pour
un chômeur du monde pour les cours ici
donc quand tes adversaires veulent
absolument gagner parce que du coup tu
es en contre tu connais absolument tout
je peux faire nul
mais c'est une d'ouverture très très
très dur jouer à maîtriser ouais mais
bon on ensuite avec faste à l'heure tu
vois caruana quand il a gagné les
candidats il jouait là petrov et l'année
peau qui domine les candidats ils jouent
là petrov c'est quand même une belle
ouverture pour
pour les tournois d'éviter dites élites
quoi
après ou bon moi je trouve que c'est
quand même
un fort vent vie quoi
mais c'est très solide
après n'est pas il joue là petrov avec
tellement d'heures de travail derrière
que c'est pas la même petrov que tout le
monde allait solide ça pétera et on voit
pas beaucoup de karo kann c'est vrai que
moi j'attends des macarons cannes cannes
de la part d' ali reza pareil
mais c'est une ouverture que j'aime pas
trop pour une raison simple c'est qu'en
fait je laisse le tempo blanc plutôt
je vois tu joues petrov ou marshall je
sais que joue entre le solide
qui va pas y avoir de normes ouais tu
sais que tu joues pas une major john
nash d'or tu sais que je joue pas une
petrov wynn macao cagnes est là car au
calcul laisse aux blancs décidé en fait
tu laisses le tempo est ce qu'ils
veulent jouer une prend des 500 prend
des 5s qui va jouer une avance une
facile avec les deux cas c'est toi qui
laisse le tempo quand tu veux 4,6 c'est
pour ça en fait qu'elle et moi et la
française c'est devenu trop dur l'as
vence
bas tout toutes les françaises sont très
dures française n'est pas il l'attend
est la dernière fois il a été reçu dans
ma xive où il avait pris très cher
moi tu l'avais joué au grand prix mais
têtue et ouais tu étais pas passé loin 3
quand tu l'avais joué ouais mais je n'ai
pas joué au toutou meilleur non plus
nakaya ici c'est pas né pour
ces niveaux auxquels au top niveau mais
un peu en dessous mais très dur à jouer
de toute façon une erreur dans la
française la française tu peut la
comparer un peu à l'est indienne
majeur normalement pour le prix d'un
coup quoi appâter pas vu de grob non
plus
à la pire que c'est très très très dur
il ya
sa grille chaud que vous la jouer haut
il n'était pas bien après ok je sens
ouvert sans analyse
est injuste qui campent en jeu juste
cliquer juste sans aucun risque a plus
un ennemi woods
alors qu'une belle robe ouais
on peut en avoir une de la part de
richard peut-être tu vas rire mais au
top 12 on m'a jouée comme ludwig et
comme richard hayes un k -o 4,6 de
quatre des cinq cavaliers 7 3 4 6 et du
coup tu as gagné
tu l'auras coup c'est ridicule c'est un
bon ou à gharamian à wigan on sait bien
il avait évoqué j'ai juste j'ai joué
trop vite j'ai clic clic clic je me suis
retrouvé pas traître donc on peut dire
que gharamian est un disciple de l'oubli
il a pas mal joué d'ailleurs dégradé
curseur et oui il a fait un bon tour
maintenant aussi tigran
toi tu as fais toi tu as pris 20 points
26 15 15 bah je partais très loin aussi
j'ai perdu tellement cette dernière à
nec bon après ça fait plaisir quand même
c'est à dire monte à combien
il faut encore quelques temps doit comme
ça et ça va tu veux remonter à 27 ou tu
t'en fous complètement tu cliques
aubagio clic mais c'est mieux de clics
et de bien le clic un prochain tournoi
tu veux jouer
en allemagne on va gagner un deuxième
titre par équipe en bout une bêche en
bundle
je vais le championnat de france après
albi
c'est toujours mieux de bien que l'écart
aux échecs c'est plus marrant c'est
toujours un jeu quand ça joue bien mais
ouais tu auras forte affaire il ya de
bons adversaires mais notamment jules 1
qui a passé un cap là non ouais là il
joue bien je joue bien
oui bon mais bon ya beaucoup de bons
joueurs au chomâge de france oui bien
sûr j'ai gagné la dernière fois c'était
il ya cinq ans
les deux dernières fois je vais pas
gagner
et c'est qu'elle formule du coup cette
année c'est des poules puis une phase
avancée des matches c'est directement
mari show man des matchs donc
et a déjà le tirage au sort avec les
têtes de série non non on était dedans
fin des tweets et des deux séries mais
il ya tirage au sort à peu et puis après
de toute façon ça joue je crois que
mathieu il est en deuxième partie de
tableau donc pour te dire premier tour
tu peux déjà mathieu ça peut être oui
monfort mais
oui
avons dès les quarts de finale tu as
forcément mais oui ça fait longtemps que
j'ai pas été champion de france mais
c'est vrai cyril quatre ans il n'ya pas
sûrs et met donc
voilà je n'ai pas joué la dernière et
maxime la neige avait pas joué oui c'est
ça mais bon de toute façon c'est très
dur tu as maxime lagarde jules bauer
précisé
gharamian j'imagine hayat hoffman qui va
jouer à ça ça fait très plaisir mieux si
enfin on va revoir iossif ouais ya marc
angers qui peut être pénible mais ça
fait longtemps qu'il n'a pas joué je le
rencontre pas de temps en temps de jeu
lui croisé il ya longtemps s'est
longtemps que j'ai pas croisé chez le
maraîcher de temps en temps je le croise
hockey news ciné paumé s'était déjà
quasiment signé est alors à tort par
contre on peut aller voir les raisins
peut-être
fabi c'est plus la différents âges de
fer g3
à chaque coup est très très cher là en
fait c'est dans ces moments-là
allegrezza et pas de dépenses et en tant
que ça mais en fait là c'est vraiment
3,4 coûts qui vont être absolument
clutch
way ainsi peut prendre l'aventage même
que ce soit difficile à jouer d'un côté
ou de l'autre wen
et tata déjà ton calendrier prévu à
partir de septembre ou et
je joue je pense que jouer en espagne
aussi pour
effectuer une remontée ada
descendu l'an dernier malheureusement je
n'ai pas pu jouer sont descendus tu
joues en ligue espagnole en deuxième en
deuxième mais est-ce que tu as linares
aussi du coup pas non ça sera palin rsa
sera portée au dessus de porto à travers
vers la corogne c'est ça la corogne un
peu plus bas que la corogne outrageux
porto joly parce qu'en fait on va faire
le road trip avec fab avant
allez voir les vélos garés oui oui non
loin de partir j'espère qu'ils seront
sortir avant de partir à bas il y aura
du live je pense je pense moi même pas
faire de vélo glas on va carrément faire
du live en fait on a déjà notre chemin
on va faire san sebastian ça c'est mon
club oui la réponse soit en face du
stade on passera les voir donc on va
faire san sebastian la corogne
la corogne on va aller à saint jacques
de compostelle
de saint jacques de compostelle on va
aller à fatima et de fatima à lisbonne
mais je vous allez partir combien de
temps on s'en va le faire en six jours
ces jours non en fait on a regardé on
pensait que c'était beaucoup plus loin
les stops et enfin de saint-sébastien de
la corogne ces trois heures et demie la
corogne saint jacques de composants nous
c'est à côté c'est pour ça après fatima
s'est de nouveau 3h30 4h et après c'est
de nouveau une heure une heure et demie
donc c'est la galice c'est là qu'elle y
soit offert
un beau pèlerinage bien justin ouais je
sais pas ces femmes qui m'a dit saint
jacques de compostelle on va jamais y
aller on sera à côté c'est quand même
une dinguerie ou la c4 on a ces 4
attention ces fautes ouais c'est semi
faute oui après si
c'est pas précis d'un côté
ça ça doit être analysée en plus pareil
car ou
parce que ces quatre c'est quand même
assez naturel après pas sûr c'est parce
que tu avais fous ces cathos kefu c4 il
donnait 0-0 même pas envie par contre
quatre
et ce qui fait ça pour sortir de la
prépa ou que non là il sait pas fabiano
ils crient calcul un nom et jeter les
lignes après aux 4 c'était très dur
aussi doux qu'un délit hk tu vois tu
mets ta la dame ok vraiment dur en fait
et c'est 4 c'est peut-être le cool
donkey car on doit avoir du vrai
hockey force et
c'est pas possible ils repartent il
comprend pas
ça repart avec les ics à haikou et qui
comprend pas fantastique ça repart
attend il allie icis d'ariary fait ses
petites cities grimace est là ouais en
fait j'essaie de comprendre pourquoi
c'est très dur tu joues fouday revenant
autour de 8 comme co principal et b4
ah oui pardon oui et en fait ce qui se
passe c'est qu'avec les noirs tu peux
pas jouer des quatre
tours a toujours le fouet le cavalier
qui va taper et e4 tu peux plus du tout
de jouer parce que tu as la case des
cases
et en fait ouais le cheval qui bouge pas
trop à cause de fou c'est simple
pas facile
mais il ya 8 a lancé une arène je sais
pas qui a gagné d'ailleurs ils vont nous
dire
une arena d'une heure
qui vient de finir du cou qui vient de
se terminer mais c'était pas une bay
arena juste une c'était une co à rennaz
c'était pour faire planter l'ouest
chaska ouais c'est clair qu'en 64 qui
l'a emporté dommage que ce soit pas
clinquante 83 la rouille droit un cadeau
à créneaux d'alpha échec
non 64
et scène du coup il a fini convient
enfin stentz tout maintenant tout six
tournois importants
stoute 4 3 a ou bleu bah oui à bas 23
pas c'est dommage et toutes et tous qui
s'est fait par oned
la fille ni combien de baron 24e stunt
et le baron
nono qui veut pas donner son résultat
sous steam et j'ai battu le baron jolie
et nous la semaine prochaine avant faire
qu'on s'ouvre samedi prochain on va
faire le blind test important
soutien je vais te chercher j'arrive
voilées
jouent ils jouent c4 qu'il a le choix
entre fous ces deux et food et 1
mais bon comme
la turbine elle aime bien fou d'elle
ça va être très dur pour s'il arrive à
jouer fou d1
et b4 au prochain coup ça va être très
dur pour
pour fabiano
on voit pas trop d'idée il ya les deux
pions au centre mais ni 4 ça sera un
quatre ce sera toujours
ça donnera toujours cette case
d41 l'habitude
et après fou d un oui les d4 on imagine
puis on prend puis on prend juste
cavaliers prend mais ça ça va être
quelque chose qui va essayer de faire
marcher un moment ou un autre des quatre
pour ouvrir un peu les lignes pour les
tours
et est ce qui peut penser
après fou d un cavalier cavaliers c5
vous des incas et c'est ça qu'il ya
cavaliers prendre 5
un peu bizarre sa c4
fodé un cavalier c5 ici on peut pas
jouer il faut prendre un point qui avait
promis 5 parce qu'il y avait chaque
cavalier ces cinq cavaliers prendre 5
d'un prof 5 il faut prendre ces 5 merci
au revoir
donc il va le jouer
parce que paradoxalement se fout des
trois il n'est pas si bon que ça
hikaru je sais pas qu'il prépare mais
clairement pas chris lytle john
né pour il a fait nul berline à les
sessions de marche mais il peut même
plus les faire je pense que c'est signé
ouais c'est signé on va peut-être jeter
un coup d'oeil à rapporte duda
trop complexe là on va pas y rester trop
longtemps je profite kevin n'est pas la
regarder j'ai trois
c5 ok fou
g2o b trop détroit bizarre
pourquoi b3
métro pour fo 3 c'est un peu bizarre là
ritchie
ouais bon pas l'air d'avoir de problème
pour les noirs je pense que même je
pense même que duda va pas je vais pour
gagner
si je pense que chris lytle jeune
travaille évidemment pour icare où ça
c'est évident mais il ya quelqu'un
d'autre il ya quelqu'un derrière en plus
quelqu'un de très très fort je pense du
niveau de vichy ou aniche ou gary je
sais pas pas d'idées mais je veux dire
d'un niveau
d'un niveau assez haut dessus
tu cherche un endroit pour le china qui
ouais ok ouais du coup on en est passé
là dessus mais pas le jouet b3 après
faudra blizzard est qui qui affecté 1
par la partie d'hier ça c'est sûr
ok on croise de il a joué dame f7 la
foule 3
alors toujours attention aux cavaliers
prend h3 ici on doit jouer roi prend h3
damage cinq échecs on a même cavalier h4
donc il n'y a pas du tout aux cavaliers
proches 3
mais surtout à prendre 3 je pense qu'il
va jouer feu
c'est que le cavalier déjà bien
installés en f4 j'ai peur que sur un
cavalier premier du dessin coup un tour
prend aussi du d5
donc il va dieu je vais probablement fou
prend et feu et après cavaliers h5
c'est un mini plus pour le blanc ben
ouais c'est rien de
la partie du jour c'est vraiment
le vide à 17 ans le crâne nu quand
violent je pense qu'il est avec sais pas
je pense c'est même sûr dont il a vécu
un maillage
les raisins
il a dit que c'était les pires candidats
qu'ils aient vu
mais il exagère un peu non un peu trop
il a dit que certaines parties citées
niveau de 1300 lots très bien enfin
c'est très très dur
je me
cissé 2003 j y ai un
je viens jamais parfaite c'est que ça
joue très bien mais quand tu joues
contre
contre un dépôt ou enfin bientôt des
fois battant bah ouais le problème c'est
quand il fait deux fautes et les mecs tu
termines instantanément même pas tu fais
une ou presque zéro faute
trop dur
l'an dernier tu avais hockey alexanco a
fait peut-être des très mauvaises pas
certaines très mauvaise partie certaines
très bonne d'ailleurs leurs troupes néo
polar bien joué un hyper intéressant
quand il a joué noir contre
maxime et gros dépôts ouais c'était oui
mais parce que dans le verbe fleuri
s'ajoutent revient enfin c'est mal je
trouve en face
les deux dans les vertus
wang c'est pareil bongo même s'il a mal
joué à un moment elle que les autres
jouent beaucoup mieux là cette année tu
peux avoir un richie qui
marie si en plus il a plutôt de la
réussite des tramways en rien sauf hier
ben ouais ouais mais hier et que tu sois
là qu'on a commencé quand il commence à
jouer du p3 tout ça c'est compliqué
non mais c'est dur à jouer
c'est tournoi là c'est extrêmement dur
et puis quand tu commences à être un peu
en sueur est un peu moins bien joué
tu continues à te prendre des monstres
sora tournoi où tahri doute à il a gagné
une partie de moi je crois pas
non plus lui non plus qui rajhi non plus
mais tient que naka
caruana une époque qui ont gagné mais au
bout du bout de six rondes
cette même là au bout de cette rando
louis irréel c'est à dire que même ceux
qui jouent moins bien ils sont hyper
solide arrive à battre entre eux
importance et des joueurs ouais c'est
pas des joueurs solides hyper solide ans
mais c'est tellement fou derrière jouer
bien joué il cas où je pense qu'il va la
gagner celle-là après dubaï l'a vraiment
suer dans la première il file vers il
était vraiment gagnant contre rapport 5
rocks ne pas gagner la sirène un peu
bizarre mais après faut se mettre dans
le tournoi aussi ok tu as une pression
[Musique]
mais ils ont eu aucune chose contre elle
pour avoir une chance contre les pauvres
non il ya une vie car aucune chance en
fait les crises
et dans l'autre un maxi qui avait joué
juste une partie est juste incroyable
ouais non les mecs perdent pas quoi
c'est imbattable
magnus il a perdu parce qu'il a perdu
une partie tu comptes et en plus c'est
une partie way we ve guen fin où il
pouvait égaliser le hezbollah mais c'est
pas une partie a été dominé de a à z
c'est un jeu jamais n'en veut pas perdre
leur job il était passé par mieux puis
moins bien pire mieux pire moins bien
c'était une partie c'était les montagnes
russes en fait c'est un vrai combat
magnus pourquoi magnus est le plus fort
comme ça peut-être parce qu'il n'a pas
encore joué maxime bouet les réseaux
match
un contrevenant aux dernières chances
maxime en vrai en longues après c'était
plus dur mais en rapide ou en blitz
sylvain match contre carsen
maximo rapide ou blitz iliad maxime et
gadgets d'ambert et leur style fait il
battre en orange vous raconter jeu comme
maxime et joue
au niveau même pas niveau
c'est un peu de différences de style 1
contre axiaux est sérieux c'est celui
qui prend ce qui obtient sa position il
c'est un combat asymétrique avec maxime
carlot scène ce qui est plutôt bien
ouais ça va un peu mieux la formation en
contre
j'ai l'impression aussi que magnus il
commence à cliquer un peu plus ouais
mais ça commence à glisser aussi avec
l'âge et au hockey il y en a peut-être
un peu marre de me la pète envie de se
faire plaisir quoi
mais c'est vrai que contre maxime c'est
pas forcément le style de jeu qui passe
quoi le clic parce que le clic au hasard
maximy qu'il est quand même un peu reçu
quoi il a plus d'expérience il est un
petit peu au courant du clic au hasard
maxime effectivement
[Musique]
une jolie idée la donne est
donné par lord il ya du cavalier hdh un
f2 qui peut arriver
trouvable et jolie en plus
là un problème de mobilité ou pas des
pions centraux
a response serait pas là on fait un
résumé express va qui tous les jours et
ce qu'on ne ferait pas sur cette partie
là résumé express
de l'ouverture de la partie qu'on
regarde
les petits rideaux
allez petit résumé express avec baky sur
la parra temps on va regarder quand je
regarde quand est ce qu il a joué la
nouveauté vas-y si tu veux si tu veux
faire un régime expression est vraiment
exprès expression on est
en fait on sait non je sais pas si tu as
vu les vidéos sur youtube on s'est lancé
dans le format express
mais oui tu peux nous dire où est la
nouveauté pas mais on va cliquer vita on
va pas expliquer vraiment les des coûts
cdu express
ceibal résumé express
d'ailleurs n'hésitez pas là pendant que
baky regarde à nous dire ce que vous en
pensez sur youtube si vous les avez
regardés l'ailé ce en entier la passeuse
pour les ouvertures pour pour twitter et
pour pour les gens qui arrivèrent vers
16 heures 16 heures 15
alors je sors pour nous tuer pour pour
pour vous même plus que pour nous mêmes
pour nous à foix iii ça a été jouée par
fabiano
contre vente forest
on ne te reste à jouer des tours à des
huit
dames 1 il faut et 5
nuls pour trois jouées par fabiano
ff5 c'est une nouveauté
c'est fabiano qui joue faux f5
nouveautés fou p3a attend ça peut
retomber
dans l'église énorme blender d'alireza
je obligé d'aller voir parce que sinon
c'est oui je te le dis regarde cavaliers
pros trouve non je n'y a pas une noble
honda cbf
c'est pour mettre un band alba qui
après je préférais frau 3 oui mais on
peut pas dire énorme brenda par
majuscule en plus
c'était tu fais valdes est vraiment
ouais mais la retraite ou non n'ont même
pas à
aa
non mais méritée parce qu'en fait au
début du tournoi y en avait trop qui
faisait ça pour nous faire changer de
parti
au bout d'un moment vont pouvoir avoir
un truc cohérence que la taille ils nous
coupent en fait dans ce qu'on est en
train de dire
oui trouvé trois tours à des vitesses
que ça retombe alors ça retombe pas
parce que dans la partie il a joué donc
tour à des huit d'amr france info pro f
5 à bien nos et cette haine élevé mais
ça pouvait retomber en fait ça arrive
que massa aurait plus donc il n'a pas
joué trois des 8
3 rendez vous
donc au stade
après dam des deux il faut pas jouer
c'est calme jouer quatre vallées h4
dalcin
et là c'est compliqué food et un daf ou
d aide à toutes les pièces qui arrivent
trop complexe ouais non mais oui c'est
très dur à jouer sur l'échiquier
passe alors du coup
bas qui n'inquiète pas c'est vraiment
exprès t'inquiète pas ça va très très
vite
ça va ça va très c'est vraiment beau
format vers les aravis exprès des
parties complètes ce qui est beau c'est
qu'on montre maximum deux variantes de
trois coups dans toute la partie c'est
bon je sais mais toi on mais c'est un
nouveau format mais les gens tu vois les
gens qui aiment bien les gens qui aiment
moins mais c'est quand même pas mal dans
le sens où alors vous allez deux moments
c'est que contre maxime à bucarest il a
joué down the way et qu'il a joué
lui-même fou 3 way home sales c'est à
nouveau un héros fait les gars rouge
tout tempo et c4 ses fautes t'inquiète
on va réussir à faire face à l'est on a
tous et on a remis et a remis léger mais
l'échiquier être le format grands
honneurs en honneur aux noces donc les
amis aujourd'hui on suit la partie nakta
murat caruana grosse partie du jour en a
qu à murat qui essayent de revenir à
niveau et donc on va vous montrer ça
avec etienne etienne c'était une
espagnole à la maxime
l'espagnol ouverte ça fait partie des
variantes possibles de fabiano
donc ça a cliqué la grande variante on
avait vu que maxime a déjà joué sa
première est qu'on décrit non contre
mamediarov sur début d'année au grand
prix fidh donc ça a pris en f2
f6 pion de cavaler f1 puis on prend un
5-3 gerin est ici première surprise baky
d'amd 6 au lieu d'amener cette de quoi
important les dames 17 ça a été jouée
par fabiano contre maxime à bucarest
donc il a mis là notamment des six fou
ou trois échanges et fouet f5 nouveautés
théorique de fabiano donc à ce moment de
la partie baky on pense que c'est
caruana qui a la meilleure préparation
savoir que caruana jouait lui-même faut
3 1 il a joué veulent vendre au reste le
bûcheron lui a joué des tours à des 8,5
dont qui joue sa nouveauté mais bon
icaro ils rigolent et éclectique four b3
tempo qui entoura des huit pour protéger
le pion damien il décale s'appelle une
arrivée de la tour cavaliers à cinq
dames f2 top 6 5 ap c5 pour jouer
l'enfilade qui avaient des pcet défend
la case prépare à c5 tourer 1 ces cinq
quand même jouer pour placer un gros
centre mais hikaru qui paniquent pas
cavalier g3 touche le fou fou détroit et
dames des deux est ici apparemment
d'après les grosses chaleurs
la première réflexe groupe tempo de
hikaru aux réflexions de de fabiano et
il trouve pas le coup de la turbine de 4
qui était difficile très difficile ça
laisse du cavalier h4 il ya les pièces
qui arrivent donc il a joué ses calculs
humains c4 et après une petite réflexion
et carouge où le bon coup dernier les
change pas les foudres de cases blanches
et ici le problème des noirs c'est quand
même du mal à pousser baki alors on peut
pas pousser des quatre parce que je
comprends et puis on prend cavaliers
prend on tape trop de fois et on peut
pas pousser hauts cadres parce qu'on
avait les cases noires le fou détroit
qui est un magnifique en fait c'est un p
et là on peut un plan blanc possible
c'est de jouer b4 déjà au prochain coup
pour garder la case c'est ça qui
empêchait le cavalier b celle de bouger
parce qu'à la pression j'en aurai une
super casse pour le four c'est ça qui
tapent des six avaient fui partout et
une autre idée de leur dit d'aller
déloger le foot est roi par cavalier h
un cavalier f2 donc position difficile
pour fabi qui a déjà une demi heure de
retard on verra ce que ça donne
même un bon résumé un maquis express ça
c'est beau c'est à nice express quoi
ces bimbos on envoie la pub et puis pour
un café en
café tuant match
après
après ouais non mais là il va planter
fabi du coup
il va planter enfin mis à réfléchir
longtemps très très dur à jouer mais ce
n' est pas il doit être content quand
ils voient ça oui ça c'est des positions
que le h joue très bien
et là ouais ouais
j'ai trouvé ça je trouve le la prépa
d'hikaru incroyable depuis le début la
confirmation way
est très dur d'aller l'échoppé de se
rappeler de tout ça parce que
famille il peut être joué en marshal
comme il a joué contre maxime ont
compris ouais on la partie
il peut jouer la casaque
way lablad c5 way la foux c5 qui a joué
au premier candidat compte matière
peut jouer plein d'autres ouvertures
mais sur cinq je l'avais joue déjà les
il peut jouer là petrov temps mais ils
peuvent jouer toutes les mines où tu
dois avoir 18 idées comme comica
et il est vraiment impressionnant écart
inédit qui pourrait s'il le souhaitait
revenir dans le haut niveau
ouais mais alors il a toujours été très
fort dans la tour 17
il va aller en s est pas si mal il va se
prendre des cuatro ici
ouais après avec les blancs il a
toujours été
quand il a des idées date en juin mais
surtout avec 4 d'ailleurs il a perdu
quelques parties avec ses 4 il ya des
positions qui maîtrise moins bien mais
on peut se souvenir de sa partie à
londres il ya 4 5 ans d'âge d'or
même là tu dois t'en souvenir je veux
dire il a eu quelques idées comme ça
quelques fulgurances avec les volants
avec les blancs mais avec les noms il a
plus de mal c'est dur de tenir le
d'ailleurs ils changent pas d'ouverture
avec les morts je suis pas sûr qu'il le
top-3 longtemps hikaru il est passé top
donne et elle a fait de même ouais papa
tu es tu ne parles réparti le prix d'une
partie
non je suis pas hyper fier à renommer
partie gondry caro
s'était un peu dommage la deuxième
fallait que je gagne mais c'est trop dur
ouais c'était dur et la première il a
très bien joué contre moi il a bien il a
très très bien joué les carreaux dans la
première mais j'étais quand même un peu
un peu plus agréables de la pause du
côté un peu plus agréable mais je suis
pas assez fort pour lui on lui poser des
vraies des vrais problèmes danser dans
ses positions
pour moi c'était peut-être un peu dur à
ce moment là et on ne voyait pas aussi
fort aussi à nous de notre côté un an
qu'ils reviennent on le sentait être un
peu moins bien et puis finalement il est
revenu très fort en fait ils jouaient
déjà top niveau mondial on ne savait pas
sur ces grands prix au final bon a le
premier évoqué le groupe était très fort
allez-y
on s'attendait pas à ce qu'ils soient si
rares moi je m'attendais à ce qu'il soit
moins fort écart ou bien su mais il
l'était pas à ce niveau là du tout enfin
pas au niveau de maintenant jouer comme
un top 10 peut-être entre top 8 et hop
dose on va dire la plus le jour
autour des 7 joueurs et b4 qui va partir
pour hikaru b4 j'aime beaucoup parce que
ça prend vraiment alors s'il n'y a pas
de dégâts de faire toujours attention
des cats qui peuvent arriver parce que
les
là il va les noirs ils ont besoin
d'ouvrir la position pour pour leur tour
à 30 river et sinon ils vont se faire
attaquer les pumas est obligé de pousser
un moment donné ils vont donner toutes
les cases en fait
toujours attention aux des cuatro
fabiano qui se lève on le met un peu en
grand plan sympa de voir les joueurs
comme ça aussi voilà c'est la partie du
jour très clairement elle peut elle peut
changer beaucoup de choses et sicav ou
gagne c'est vrai que caruana il sera un
point un point de retard ça commence à
être beaucoup un sarko n'est pas il va
pouvoir être vraiment en gestion c'est
la partie de demain qui va être un
paquet caruana zepos demeure absolument
décisif c'est complètement finie parce
qu'en plus ce n'est pas blanc contre les
quarts où va-t-on car il va jouer il va
fermer je vais peut-être même rejoindre
4/4 ailier est ce qu'ils trouvent des
quatre là pas facile quand même à m et
ses danses orange
on est pourri car ou ici pourra pour
qu'ils reviennent se mêler à la course
quand même ce serait sympa
thierry tout 59 qui édifie saluer ludwig
il n'est pas là l'autre veille n'en est
pas un il est venu clip il exact mais il
est reparti vers parti à la plage ludwig
est important
mais même on l'a perdue avec les
défaites d'anyresa mais bon on va le
retrouver dès le grand prix zagreb
maximo la clique c'est rapide ou -selon
zagreb c'est rapide c'est rapide et de
blatten et les longues du coup c'est
c'est la sinne que fils du coup ça prend
septembre ouais c'est fin septembre même
sévi fin ou des bus à présent quelque
chose comme ça parfait ça va être sympa
ça paraît après le championnat de france
aux bataves à saab est à ouidah savent
c'est le tournoi commence à 20h on finit
à minuit avec sarah craquer avec les
victoires de maxime ya de quoi se faire
aux grenats jda c'est du vécu et en plus
y'a murat maxime y aura ma news sur à
lyon lille reza ouais c'est un très beau
tournoi roues
et non et non et elle ne joue pas le
championnat de france
trop peur trop peur de moi ça pourrait
être bon il y avait le journal france
avec ali reza et mvele falloir augmenter
les prix de ryan prize pool il va
falloir augmenter le prize pool mais on
espère
ça ferait un beau tournoi il est déjà
ball tournoi mais
ce sera un des plus forts championnats
nationaux en fait avec
maxime à gaza ce serait quasiment au
niveau du championnat des usa
risqueraient même
championnat de russie on n'aurait rien à
leur envier
commandera peut-être commentera
peut-être la finale kévin à ça dépend
qui ya ses dépens qu'il y ait ça se
défend kia parce que je suis réaliste
finale corner touba qui voit si tu joues
je commenterai
si l'internet tient ce qu'on sera encore
au portugal ou à linares
vous passez par les dresse le fab sur le
retour doit jouer une ou deux parties à
linares comme ça tu peux aller à l'hôtel
hannibal ouais voilà ou à jouer
jouer est un des plus grands fantasmes
tic
donc oui sur le retour ça dépendra de
fab si vous paraît qu'ils coupent à
eaubonne l'aiment bien et caro quand
même je sais pas c'est les gens qui ne
sont même pas c'est terrible
à ne pas trop en lique à
obama si on troll pas ça va plus
est-ce que
on peut peut-être laissé la came m un
peu à l'irena
saljic alireza avec les blancs dans la
partie en dessous de nous
il a mille cavaliers longent et 4
d'accord
ils jouent pour des 4 1 mais ce qui peut
le jouer
il joue pas pour g3 en fait dans cette
partie
à la g3 il pourrait pas du tout ça fait
bien rire voilà qu la nef attend une
petite seconde ya juste hikaru qui vient
de jouer la curiosité m'appelle il a
joué
fouet f2
il s'est levé il est parti
tu le sens pas trop dans le web non je
te vois et
je vois la tête de ba qui je me dis fuck
the ça a pas l'air d'être un bon coup tu
me regardent d'un oeil furtif
je veux attaquer le bouton ouais je veux
mais comme ça j'aime pas trop
vite fait bon après je sais que l'ordi
données b4 mais même en général parce
qu'en fait tu avais deux plans
soient cavalier a choqué plus tard cali
à chaque et avait deux soirs ouachin
fougères
pour pas avoir le visage dix ans la
sueur f
et aussi peut-être passé barrage 3 x h
de tf1 pour ouais mais il faut être deux
comme sa vision en fait c'est aussi
visuel tu vas passer juste bons à prête
à pessac est très direct cable un peu
simple mais
quel tour 7 il va faire des cadres donc
ça va faudrait pas que touré vii pu
marcher pour quatre là tu menaces 4
machin sur quels points 4 bref de hutus
reprendre cinq taureaux f3 a priori
donc
ok toute façon rien je vais clic à côté
un pur oui pour être compliqué mais la
confirmation elle j'aime pas trop trop
utiliser leur dit mais bon la partie
elle est trop importante ils sont trop
forts pour faire puissent analyser ce
serait du rapido tué paméla
oui là pour essayer de voir un peu la
complexité
des calculs peut-être pas bien
il car ou
là par contre c'est vrai comme on le
disait en avant match comme on l'a
répété
s'ils gagnent pas cette partie là ce
sera vraiment à 100% une course à deux
[Musique]
ok il ya un super coup sûr tour des eps
vii
qu'il a pris à bail l'avion plus désolé
fantastichini un super coup
on vous le laisse
il a vu une dinguerie abbas est un super
coup oui c'est beau c'est beau en fait
et encore mieux que les deux plans que
je donnais c'est quoi le coup pas facile
c'est ça pour ça et ça
c'est ça
cavalier à chelsea
il de fous j'ai trois cavaliers end
c'est hyper bien joué ouais trop dur
trop c'est dur très dur très dur
donc il en forme ah oui non ça c'est
très très dur
ok donc c'est très très bien joué en
fête ou f2 et surtout recettes peut-être
qu'il faut qu'un voyage
je sais pas là mais
après si tu forces tour cet été assez
content comme ça va la fin l'important
c'est que tous rêvent 7
est quand même très joli ah ouais non
c'est très très bien joué
ouais et calcule bien
l'effort et que
les calculs bien je pense mais du coup
d'essai c'est pas un et
etc j'ai toujours remarqué quand je
jouais contre lui
par sa technique quand il est mieux elle
est pas naturelle
c'est pourquoi ouais ouais calcul c'est
vraiment tu prends les risques mais t'as
pas peur
s'est pas tu vois c'est clair que
n'importe qui
un puceau et mieux tu fais b quattro et
après du bois comment tu transfères et
l'a envoyé fouet faisaient cavalier à
schaffhouse et 3 bravo quoi ah ouais
c'est du cdu n'a qu'à dans le découvre
même bijou patron comme ça non
maintenant ils jouent alors si il a
obligé un missile obligé même s'il est
obligé alors que la et
ikaros il a plusieurs choix
c'est celui qui jouera le plus souvent
le moins naturel fois où le mois passé
moi oui il va en 2012 tout en force car
pourquoi ce plan est fort parce que
tu mets tu vas tu ape 5 et tu va taper
des trois fêtes c'est ce qu'on veut
faire ce qu'on voulait faire avec ali al
sharif deux vont taper des trois mois
les croyants à fougères pour taper avec
h3 fourrage 2 comme on disait mais là en
fait tu fais les deux dont tu gagnes en
oeuvre de tempo gagne plus ouais et le
plaisir tempo avec la pièce mieux placé
et plus
donc fabi way qui commencent à s'en
rendre compte la ville a dû être assez
content en fait au moment
au moment de foi f2 est là la savate anc
carreau il n'a pas été que dans l'ombre
de magnus il n'a pas été le seul dans
l'ombre de magnus ils le sont plus ou
moins nombreux
à aimer ce magnus il a vraiment
régné en maître sans laisser la moindre
miette un carreau je sais pas moi je ne
trouve pas du tout le plus
non mais j'étais dans le gruppetto quand
j'étais dans le groupe et aurait dans le
temps moment dit clairement dans top 5
si oui mais pas à clermont 2
étaient un peu d'eux comme gris chaud
qualité
mais ça va pas durer non aux failles
carreaux donc le car on a vu la mise à
part caruana en fait c'est le seul à
voir car wallace est le seul qui a
vraiment duré mais même moi je trouve
que même
ouais ouais encore tv land
fort qu'eux mais le seul qui a vraiment
qui c'est vraiment installé installés
sans carbone il a failli y passer un il
était à quoi il est à 5 6 points et
laurent moment donné mais c'est trop
d'énergie au bout d'un moment enfin
quand on dit stop il a levé le pied un
petit peu
même si remis c'est peut-être
les quelques mois en dessous
on peut moins travaillée qui vont lui
faire défaut au final c'est aussi la
force de manu c'est que même quand il
joue pas très bien il continua dans
l'excellence quoi
son menu s'il joue rarement pas très
bien qu'on allait venir pas très bien
par rapport à ses standards jamais
souhaité par rapport à ses cendres il
reste dans l'excellence ouais mais le
truc c'est que
déjà il fait très peu dormi
il fait tout le temps des échecs sur
l'échiquier
wade exo il a beaucoup d'entraîneurs il
ya beaucoup de moyens
et où il tout simplement plus fort un
après il a un style peut-être qui
demande moins d'énergie d'un placement
de pièces naturel vraiment incroyable
peut-être moins d'énergie en dehors de
l'échiquier sur l'échiquier non mais non
mais oui mais en dehors peut-être que
c'est bas c'est plus du talent naturel
pour le chéquier coquet fabi sa force de
travail une accusation
que les ouvertures pourquoi il est si
fort beaucoup qui ont autant de lignes
que fally mai mais qui les connaît aussi
bien en fait qu à l'ue et au fmi
c'est hélas aujourd'hui se fait attraper
dans l'ouverture
ça va dans le sens de ce que tu disais
avant enfin au début de la partie car où
il travaille avec du très lourd
magnus et une endurance supérieure à
tous les autres j'aime et de loin je
suis pas sûr wei un prétendu ans mais
aussi un côté où il peut mais magnus
hitchock aussi assez souvent quand il
est dans la difficulté il n'y a pas trop
de différence avec les autres sais pas
mais bon il est rarement en difficulté -
avec les autres mais oui mais oui c'est
ça alain compte maxima il a été vraiment
pas loin de la perdre celui qui a
augmenté son niveau de deux pas de choc
c'est une époque les remet en oui mais
on est poli de choquer pour ça qu'il
était il arrivé dans le top 5 il ya deux
ans en fait oui oui mais parce qu ils
étaient capables alors qu il aurait pu
rentrer bien avant mais il est en fait
tout le travail qu'il a fait qu'on a
fait pour lui mais qu'il a fait aussi
lui-même
il tschopp quasiment plus la tchaux cuir
au niveau quand ils jouent karl scène à
fond pendant sept huit partis après tant
de prépa caire moment oui là quelque
chose qui s'est cassé est fini mais
largué je pense qu'il va il va aller
jusqu'au bout assez facilement fait
écoute on verra j'espère quand même que
caruana oui car on nous offrir un vrai
duel ouais non mais dans il va aller au
bout
tu veux il va pas donner deux parties
quoi peut il va il va arriver un
réussira il va pas avoir de fringale
quoi c'est ça comme il a pu avoir vaincu
pour le battre il va falloir faire comme
maxime
énorme partie ou comme aujourd'hui une
énorme près pas plus une grosse partie
ces trains peut-être de réaliser hikaru
ce que caruana peut faire re 4 ici le
problème de 4 en fait c'est que ça donne
la case
et du coup en fait on a plus de cases
noires on a tous les pions sur blanc on
a le foot cases blanches et on a les
blancs qui joue sur kazan noir et après
tout rêve cette
foule
3 j'imagine donc envoyé à chaouchi avait
plutôt folle 3 et là il n'ya pas de la
case f1 et détenus est bon il n'y a pas
de tactique à base d'atom projet 3 ça
donnerait la case h 2 dommage ça va tu
es jolie ça ça aurait pu aurait pu faire
mal
ouais c'est ça toute la difficulté de
caruana qui va devoir aussi composer
avec son retard au temps il joue tour df
sept as et là on va voir si la halle
cavaliers à chaud wesh quasiment sûr
qu'il fera s'il arrive à tempo
lecavalier h il fait très mal ouais
et famille doit avoir quelque chose
contre cavalière achat il a peut-être
une petite idée on peut voir des on peut
mettre des des chevaux mv non on peut en
berry vient tu peux en cliquant
là
aubin en plus on peut même faire un truc
comme ça
tu es content ah bah oui bah là il a sa
place 1 on n'utilise pas on n'utilise
pas beaucoup mais là là il a sa place en
plus c'est pour
ces pour toucher les cases noires à la
base est par contre s'il a passé un peu
c'est un peu la clim
non mais il l'a c'est sûr mais sinon ça
fait aucun sens
au boss il l'a passé le mur de thé nul
qui parle mais c'est sûr qu'il l'a
ouais c'est sûr
ce qui ne serait pas en train de nous
faire une feinte du regard à regarder de
l'autre côté de l'échiquier
il n'est pas bien fabien il sait que il
sait que ça va arriver et qui va suer
c'est terrible
et qui avoue qu'il peut gagner grâce à
mazet
peut le faire
on ira voir les autres partis après mais
là trop important l'important pour le
trop trop trop important trop beau en
plus on sait que c'est ok un coup pareil
un coup pareil ça va être dans tous les
oui ça va être sur toutes les premières
pages c'est fantastique cavaliers h1
sais je sais c'est joli et puis c'est
fort en plus immagini mais sur sur sa
miniature mais il met le mal-aimé cheval
mvl it le demande groupe i bat les loups
de vie ce que je peux te prendre votre
chevalet mevel non tu ne peux pas
je regarde un peu serré capoue pas un
écart du taux non pas du tout non je
regarde les yeux mais pas ceux du
contingent doit regarder quand même
maintenant sympa en art et celui contre
n'est pas vous c'est intéressant normal
en fait j'aime bien amer j'ai pas eu le
temps là et même les tiens je regarde
les d'ailleurs géante l'express j'ai
cliqué l'express ah bah oui c'est
important mais bon format express aux
formes
c'est qu'enfin le le grand-angle
fantastique à le grand-angle et plus
qualitatif mais l'express c'est pas mal
ou non je suis juste
sur twitter oui mais très solide et sûr
qu'il l'avait
il va se lever la norme et se lève pas
dans ilm acquise un peu là
il est pas bien fabiano bon il avait
aussi là il l'avait aussi mais bon il
est pas bien quand même
incroyable secours
c'est le coup du tournoi de chaux pour
moi ouais ccqf 2 qui est vraiment de
faim car elle est la chasse à la pelle
mais c'est l'appel de balle en fait foi
f2 qui est vraiment dure
alors
question me dumas qui ce temps c'est que
tu regroupe
tu mets le fou en g3 le fou qui va taper
le 5 et le cavalier qui arrive en f2
déjà qu'ils qui
stabilise un peu le roi le cabinet wave
2 mais qui tape aussi sur sur le fou et
qui va provoquer un petit au quattro un
moment là tu vas prendre la caisse des 4
tu prends tout quoi si on regarde qui
lui a ajouté
ahoua voilà non mais là ok là il ya tout
le monde enfin c'est juste
c'est juste pas possible d'en rire c'est
fantastique c'est fantastique
c'est absolument fantastique leur passé
en grand échiquier un risque à la dh ils
ont raison dans le tchat j'ai trois
cavaliers f2
voilà ça va attendre combien de temps il
a dépensé hikaru mais enfin de neuf
minutes c'est terrible allais-je
quasiment trois balles à ces niveaux
stockfisch l'eau ouais enfin c'est
niveau champion du monde enfin c'est
vraiment il a il fait la partie
exceptionnelle ici il n'y avait pas une
partie soutient il revient à combien de
régner un ami wayne mr ouai il peut
encore en fait il aura son château noir
comme maxime j'ai gagné au noir dur
faisable à 300
ha non c'est pas échec et stratégies non
non c'est pas le même cavalier à chaque
jeune enzo vie c'est pas le même niveau
là il est vraiment très très très graves
pour que pour que quand je vois fou et 2
j'ai peur oui oui tu dis c'est mon achat
oui c'est que c'est très dur
à bas ce soir ouais on va pouvoir
regarder le récap du facile à gaz mais
si la glande il va pouvoir chanter ce
soir il va jointes et il va pouvoir
faire le mac parce que là il va faire le
malin fond la sinne gagne c'est vladimir
qui a dit que c'était le pire tournoi
des combrailles ça ça
oui oui
la question à vlad non mais après tu
vois moi je disais par contre qu'on
avait peut-être un biais cognitif enfin
c'est un truc que je me suis à auto
analyse et c'est que le fait que nepos
soit fait autant écraser entre
guillemets dans le score contre carl
scène je te parle pas du match ça c'est
pour vous parce que moi j'étais au
contraire paraît ce que j'ai reparlé
c'est pour ça qu'il ya ce biais
cognitifs mais c'est bizarre que
cramique il l'est c'est ce que je veux
dire pour les joueurs amateurs je peux
comprendre que ça fasse cette impression
là ouais mais c'est pas enfin winger
sépia la part du kram ni hockey n'est
pas il a perdu une partie en fait
roumégous après c'était fini c'est ça le
problème ça je sais mais je parle du
follower amateurs qui regardaient parti
tu as dynepo il s'est quand même fait il
a pris cher contre carleton et je suis
d'accord avec toi ça vous sur une partie
on l'a déjà expliqué plusieurs fois mais
et ça ça peut donner cette perception
donc un amateur pense que c'est un
tournant des candidats faible je le
comprends mais cramique bah oui ou non
il ya quelques parties qui ont pas été
sublime ça c'est sûr mais
regardez il ya aussi toute façon les
fautes elles sont elles arrivent quand
tu as de la concurrence non mais
regardez dernier ad il ya quand tu fais
de la regarde on peut dire
cependant le suppose que fab hyper cette
partie on dira quoi il a fait une
mauvaise partie là non oui oui mais je
peux te cherche quand même ok pourquoi
tu joues c4 pourquoi toi là tu fais un
mauvais coup tu es sous pression tu fais
un mauvais coup mais pour faire pour
jouer des mauvais coups faut être sous
pression oui bien ces mecs là quand ils
sont tus leur pose pas de problème ils
vont pas ils vont pas faire d'erreurs
donc un match physique non en français
on peut avoir ce biais cognitifs et le
deuxième c'est que alireza joue un peu
en dessous mais là il fait pas bon tout
ça
mais mm et sa partie et qu'on ne fuit
contre caro elle est magnifique mais il
de son côté que ça soit ça près pas
après si il ya quelques unes
mais sa famille est là bas mais regarde
même sa part tu comptes douteux elle est
très correcte des deux côtés oui aux
joueurs de gagner un tel que tu peux pas
oui oui non c'est trop dur en fait
ça joue quasi parfait après bon comment
il s'appelle richard je pense qu'il fait
une très mauvaise peut peut-être
regarder vite fait les autres parties
comme là il va planter
on va y revenir évidemment
décousu cette partie
mais la partie de richard contre caruana
je peux pas dire que c'est une mauvaise
partie combat en ce sens hier un combat
nommé richard le truc ouais mais hier ça
la plante est complètement non non bien
sûr mais ça ouais sa première partie a
été un peu spéciale aussi mais bon après
il ya toujours eu ça dans les candidats
il ya toujours sabaot est à l'attention
après j'avais trouvé que ceux de moscou
avait été particulièrement fort les
candidats de moscou
c'était avec sow qui rit ce cas rien qui
n'a gagné
ouais mais c'est très chaud et c'est des
joueurs très solutions d'impression qui
a passé les arts ouais mais oui mais si
oui mais c'est faisable des joueurs je
quitte qui te provoque les orques
mais la dernière édition bail avec un
moment garou à l'iccn cause c'était
quand même en dessous de ce qu'on voit
en ce moment il n'y a pas de joueurs qui
sont aussi des tâches et la par
l'arrière ce que rajhi a tu vois qui est
censé être en dessous
on verra à la fin ri j'ai un peu venir à
-4
est bon on a mené pour et caruana qui
joue particulièrement bien aussi
maintenant dernier et avait fait maxime
est né pauvre
on verra comment ça finit ya dix mairies
qui pourrait un peu mieux reynard
coureurs il a raison en fait c'est dur
dans ces moments là quand tu sais que tu
pourquoi il va planter enfin pourquoi il
va réfléchir longtemps parce que auquel
on voit que c'est mieux pour les blancs
et du coup il doit se réadapter
et et s'est pas fait c'est très dur de
trouver des coûts tu peux pas te
résigner à jouer abbassi joue vite en
fait joujou à 4 ok il clique en fait
écrit quoi
alors en vieux 4 1 mais il a dû partir
du principe qu'en fait ça après x 2k
rédigé trois il est obligé et dont il
préfère commencer
les coûts sont durs encore fois c'est
sûr
mais quatre n'ont pas sur
ta aussi le plan qui avale y est j'ai
cinq cavaliers h 3 kg trois fous des
cats
ces cavaliers des 4 tu pars sur coup
après acheter
h3 fuji trois
exactement est après karine f2 g43 j'y
arrive ouais
patients là il ya encore une question au
cas très bien joué ouais ça pose la
question
qui a validé quatre sacs
et des quatre cas comment il faut
[Musique]
puis je veux pas trop davantage du hbh a
ainsi réussi à organiser ces pièces en
fait il peut se mettre sur les 15 morts
avec les chevaux il doit faire très
attention et à quelqu'un il ya matin f1
faut faire très attention m'attend et
femmes
peut-être un cavalier g5 intéressant
qui allie h3 plutôt heavy 6 parce que là
tu laisses cavaliers j'ai trois tables à
raison
cavaliers
voir on peut peut-être faire même
[Musique]
moquée voyage 3
l'avocat des quatre
qui pour remplacer
trois cavaliers aussi s'il va jouer des
quatre lui même ok
là les noirs vont pouvoir jouer des
quatre cavaliers des quatre logique bloc
mécaniquement en fait l'arrivée du pion
et sur
dame f6 menace rien heureusement
lâche un qu'ils veillent au grain en
sont pas bougé
comme le montrait une fois
villa de maths oui il n'y a pas besoin
de la dame en plus pour rire oui y en
avoir
deux trois coups là on a envie avec les
blancs de jouer et cavaliers âgés 3 x 3
août si on y arrive ou de mettre un
cavalier en e3 il ya aussi du cavalier
ces deux cavaliers enfin je sais pas
il se fout en d1 tête je pars si on peut
les envoyer en g4 à un moment donné pour
avoir du fou et six en tout cas c'est
encore un gros une grosse partie est
pensé que ce serait le 4 c'est vraiment
bien je pensais que les blancs
s'installerait
facilement
mais c'est pas le cas et il va falloir
jouer à base de h3 fougères trop
complexe ah oui attention à eau
regarde ce qui est ce qui est important
dans les calculs
c'est quand on va jouer h3 fou g3
surtout ref un échec on va devoir jouer
rouages de tout de suite heureusement
parce que si tout reprend tout en rage
de il ya tourteron achats in app engine
3 qui est sympa ce de justesse mais ça
passe juste
si on arrive à jouer h3 fou j'ai trois
rouages deux cavaliers f2 cavaliers g4
retombée ok mais bon il il a raison
d'avoir joué vite aux quatre familles il
gère bien son temps c'est que c'est
quelque chose qu'on a un peu
c'était un des points faibles d'alireza
dans ce tournoi mais c'est vrai que
la question du temps elle est importante
aussi aux échecs c'est pas parce qu'ils
ont deux heures qu'ils ont réellement le
temps en fait non mais là il est vite
quoi il a compris qu'il n'était pas très
bien donner à soissons il a compris
qu'il allait être obligé de le jouer aux
quatre un moment ou un autre donc il
clique et donkey ouais il a l'expérience
vous
quitte fort
important de cliquer vite et bien
[Musique]
clic vite surtout oui bien vient
s'asseoit zarrou et ça dépend où ça
tombe ça peut tomber ou ne pas tomber
regarde pas du tout parce qu'on le
regarde en allait partir d'ailleurs mais
il a joué aux quatre trop tôt et ce à un
moment où j'ai dit va planter en fait ne
va pas planter du tout après firme déjà
on va le voir et attention il accueille
38 minutes 38 minutes pour quatorze
coups compliqué oui car en plus je pense
qu'il va essayer de jouer vite et de
mettre la pression si le peu way is il a
besoin à un moment d'être très précis il
va plus loin il prendra la tente à ce
moment là rennes
mais sinon il va cliquer
ont fait un petit un petit tour des
stades nous a dit qu rapporte
ça se passait très mal
je sens que j'ai 5 à 4 un thème habituel
il va prendre d'un proche 5h quatre
cavaliers h 7 suivi d'un projet 5 ça
ressemble un peu à la deuxième partie
maxime contre richard il n'y avait pas
tactiquement c'était même un peu dans ce
thème ça c'est vrai bel avantage noir
avec un seul bronze regardions la torah
7 comme dans la partie d'alireza latour
underground qui verse à la même
structure à l'envers est tout acquis et
qui à
leur monte à 50% je crois
il n'a pas gagné mais mais il n'est pas
en difficulté en tout cas
mon cas et puis c'est une partie trop
décousu la cepap and à la meilleure
partie
ali reza qui a réussi à se placer ça
c'est bien à une à une position à erevan
ouais comment il a fait pour réussi qui
pour
cavaliers gien ok peut-être ok il n'a
pas été précisé
voilà ça veut dire aller cooder acquis
un bal à trélat je pense qu'
il peut vite avoir une très très très
bonne position à ce que les cavaliers
pranger 400 possibles quant à jouer hg
olona g5 une pièce en h j'ai cinq là il
va mettre sa tour en trois ans qu'il
ment et après jouer pour d4
il va bientôt peut-être tour trois tours
deux dams b3 et b4 ouais on est là ça va
être en forme alors j'ai dit une bêtise
imagine 11e tour troyes et tours ont eu
deux à laisser réfléchir un peu un peu
le chat j'ai dit une bêtise mais
vous
vous avez un joli coup au noir
joli coup à noire
des cinq un peu rapide casse pattes
ça trouve et oui ça trouve toujours
faire attention petit assez tactique
mais bon dans l'idée c'est ça on
rassemble les pièces pour jouer des 4
après et on fait attention on va pas se
faire enfermer comme ça est ce que ce
serait pas le petit moment que ma
demande en prêts l'année avant que
t'arrive
et que j'ai dit que revenir plus tard
pour le faire le petit conte le petit
moment conseil livre
ce que les gens aiment bien on n'a pas
fait de ce tournoi on attend toujours
pour les conseils livre banon mais c'est
toi qui les lie c'est toi que tu les as
pas si c'est moi qui les vaut c'est pour
ça que nous on est donc toi tu perçois
tu les as tu un destin qui les rendent
les donne du coup et ce ne serait pas le
moment le petit conseil libre
bah ouais bah ça alors c'est quoi tour 3
et du cavalier f4 c'est du koweït et
tactique ce nom mais à quelqu'un qui
demandait c'est la question je sais pas
s'il est encore là mais demandez un
livre pour calculer à plus de 2000
à bahia les
balais balog d'ailleurs c'est pour tout
le monde des blogs ouais c'est vrai
parce qu'à des niveaux de laisser tous
niveaux en fait ouais big save à log
les
pendules pas trop cher
t'as pas besoin de lire mais tu peux
aller sur alfa échec il y en a une 32
euros allait bien c'est la vraie c'est
une pendule fit enfin jouer les tendres
fille d'un mec
après bah y'a plein de on a une comme en
super league on a une rubrique débutants
pour les débutants le meilleur livre
pour commencer les échecs c'est
évidemment gagner aux échecs eux non
vincere à sky vous le trouverez pas de
chez moi on y avait un mieux mais quand
même il
est bon après tactique premier livre de
tac tic tac tic week end raki c'est bien
mais c'est tellement fou c'est vraiment
bien de prendre un premier livre de
tactique perso quand bastien passer un
bon combo
le gagner des chèques étatique le
week-end ensemble ils sont sympas mais
le milieu de jeu d allegri va s' ils
sont sympa à faire les commandes et
monster plane ouais les monsters est bon
a ses entrées en fait c'est tout niveau
c'est bien
c'est bien enfin même moi je les ai fait
mais c'est bien de
1400 on va dire
parce qu'il donne des idées en fait des
idées de plan des idées un peu comme ici
quoi tu choisis entre puis tu dois
choisir c'est assez interactif c'est
sympa c'est bien fait en tout cas on a
plein de plans de plein de bons bouquins
et on attend le deuxième de moins qu'en
septembre
est ce que les finales de berne lausanne
ouais alors tu là ouais je vais bien sûr
si on va dire cinq cent mille huit cents
je dirais le plus ou moins entre
voitures commandes
wii au final je recommande le premier
c'est les finales en les enfants après
le rosen et après il ya les 100 finale
où le tour de ski pour les oui c'est
bien pour les eaux là
mais oui les san finna la connaître mais
plus dure et plus le rose nc mieux entre
1500 et 1800 je préfère l'eurozone que
que les enfants il ya un peu dur c'est
un peu dur il est beau il est très bien
non non il est très beau laissant finale
mais ça me fait toujours peur contre les
genres à 1200-1300 qui le prennent ouais
et sans oui c'est un peu ça peut être un
peu dur si c'est mieux de rosen parce
que là vous apprenez apprend les bases
d'après à
le cinéma n'est pas mal aussi mais moi
je moi je préfère le en fait le sylvain
il est bien si tu veux vraiment prendre
qu'un mais je préfère la tous les
niveaux et à tous les livres sont il
faut prendre celui qui attendait ouais
moi je préfère rester avoir un peu tout
bas dans le même style que le bloc bat à
l'état les pauvres tactique c'est la
même chose on oui enfin plus moderne
après tu peux
pas
le bloc nous on a lu parce qu'à notre
époque il y avait pas le ba ba s'est dit
récemment
et toi ton celui de morta c'est la
stratégie moderne oui la stratégie
modernise échec face à ces cellules
mortes à ça il est très bien j'ai joué à
côté du match aller des annonces tu vas
pas me tombe où naissent les gars
jouaient chic et 8 il a battu mehiaoui
tu fais la première fois ci c'est que je
n'étais pas bien
j'avais bien bas il a battu il a battu
d'ailleurs
pas le mec qui n'avait pas joué depuis
même en y la stratégie fier qua non ils
attaquent typhi il n'a pas du tout suivi
ses précédents voyages long courrier à
livrer montré d'ailleurs mur tu as a
bien aimé ce livre c'était vraiment pour
moi
il n'a vraiment rien compris mais donc
du coup ils jouent bien en plus il à
24,90 encore pourtant il a je sais pas
oui les voyais pas si
61 non mais voilà ça mais j'étais 24,90
je vais je bien aimé le jouer en fait en
fait pas du tout
détrompe-toi maquis
mais bon en tout cas vous trouvez vous
pouvez trouver ce que tout ce qui peut
vous être utile et si vous avez des
questions la patronne ne manquera pas
d'y répondre ou de demain faire part si
elle ne sait pas où on sait tout de
toute façon non non non pas quand on a
une question il me demandait un jour
enfin sauf quand on sait
le pass culture je suis pas sûr que le
pass culture c'est que dans les
boutiques
je ne sais pas on sait pas ce qu'il
situe s'est passé qui m'amène pas non
utilisés
ouais mais missclick tu veux de la vente
de pièces à l'unité tu peux demander ça
tu peux envoyer un mail
ça sera toujours possible on voit pas
horaire on l'a pas mis en place concorde
non je ne vendrai pas le pion l'un
majeur si tu m'as pris en jeu et qu'il
ya une pièce qui s'est abîmé hockey
peuvent passer un coup de fil mais on
voit un message ça du tout
moi j'ai flashé son livre avec le pass
culture m et je pense comme toi que ça
doit être genre dans les fnac ou
valverde tout le temps du hockey je sais
pas bah tant mieux ensuite je peux lui
rim
ceibal bascule sherco
ch et 3 ici je suis pas la turbine est
10 h 4 mais ouais honnêtement logique tu
h 4 h 5 mai durant ouais pas facile car
ici pas facile parce que tu as quand
même un peu envie d'acheter 3 bah oui
parce que tu invites solidifier après hk
tu peux l'avoir ricard -
nice you kiss qui a dû prendre
chéquier rôles faille chèques
des belles parties
à bas le livre de kevin c jusqu'à
2200 et l'ofii le nôtre
de débuter à 1200 bah moi c'est un livre
que je vais vous faire
toute ma famille qui est un peu
intéressés par les échecs - tu feuillets
ça leur fait plaisir oui non mais c'est
un beau livre pour nous comment c'est ça
que tu as beaucoup de gens il va le capa
blanca est bien ou pas c'est quand même
très austère le capable en cas
comparativement
oui mais ils sont
toujours là mais on peut toujours dire
moi j'ai pas lu par exemple les power of
tactique je les ai pas fait pas bien sûr
et ce qui n'existait pas en fait
moi j'ai fait les nesta tous les trucs
comme ça évidemment oui comme hmm hmm
bloc je n'ai pas fait par exemple
non je sais pas j'avais une estrade
j'avais oui oui bon terme autre chose
j'avais autre chose et puis vite tu
passes le niveau et puis voilà
mais
sinon général on dit le cas passer une
référence mais moi je les prie pour
parents de faire vivre j'ai pris le
capable en cas parce que c'est une
référence mais en fait non tu le vois il
a 100 ans et est maintenant mais par
exemple on va prendre simplement mon
système oui alors nous a tous lu oui
bien sûr mais en fait tu as les mêmes
livres en améliorer alors c'est toujours
bien voilà stratégie moderne mais la
stratégie moderne aux échecs pour moi
c'est mieux bah oui là je lis reprend en
améliorer oui et les communs et les
chants clan jack lang qui écrit un livre
sur les structures pardon enfin c'est
quand même autre chose que handke manche
à keur en dessous mouais enfin je veux
dire bon rien de comparable en fait le
niveau va où là bien sûr ouais
bah c'est un truc tout le temps quand
les gens recommande le capable en cas il
voyait peut-être mieux ton ego parce que
c'est enfin c'est juste pas possible en
fait ça peut être voilà un ca gestion
dans le même temps voilà mais moi je
préfère enfin pour comment enfin oui
mais c est et c'est logique en fait
c'est comme ma tasse ans et comme nous
on joue de mieux en mieux aux échecs mon
tout ce qu'il a les ratures chienne
c'est pas comme alors c'est pas comme la
littérature
la wii à bahreïn a demandé progression
non oui bah oui mais plus en plus tu
continues de la littérature du xviiième
xixème siècle tueur vu une époque aussi
voilà donc c'est pas sinon même
traitement des eaux voilà
alors aux échecs oui le jeu évolue et
puis un
un livre aride mais 60 parties de fisher
et ses bolides mais 60 par go fischer
c'est ça c'est indémodable parce que
c'est le joueur qu'il a écrit donc c'est
encore une autre catégorie
d'âge en plein même si quelques cours
sur une chaise comme qui sont pas mal
ouais on vrai sescam s'est globalement
bien c'est un mauvais joueur
champion
il n'était pas content que je perde moi
non plus des pas contents de perdre ils
pensaient qu'ils se qualifier en fait
il fallait que je fasse il oui parce que
si je gagnais comprendrais qu'ils
n'avaient aucune chance son club oui
parce qu'après ils perdent des partages
ouais après tu vois un livre comme
zurich 53 qui est top
qui est allé livre
j'essaie volution sur les parties 2016
par exemple oui ben c'est un peu en fait
c'est dans le même style j'ai pris dans
le même style après alors on a tous le
53 2
parce qu'en fait il y avait que ça oui
mais du coup bon c'est intéressant à
cette venue c'est un non mais c'est
sympa bien sûr mais les sabres ont assez
des livres qui rentre un peu dans des
indémodables il ya mieux mais là tu
ressens quand même un petit truc de
l'époque le par exemple page fan moi je
l'avais lu vite fait je n'ai même pas lu
je crois qu'il en a 2 j'ai même pas lu
le jeu mais passionnant
c'est pas c'était pas un bon livre alors
il y en a qui est son bon là j'ai pas
trouvé ce n'était pas un très bon joueur
je
sais du coup là il plante hikaru moments
importants h3 c'est le coup le plus
logique
hk semble être la préférence des
arrondis
j'ai vraiment les affaiblir les cases
noires
c'est beau jeu quatre aces il le trouve
le villeneuve était bien heureux
sur les finales je vais faire les gars
je l'avais fait avec lui est
un très bon joueur de finale
mais bon il c'est pareil maintenant les
nouveaux livres de finale
bah oui c'est ben oui c'est plus précis
jusqu'à les ordis parce que
et malgré deux prédécesseurs de kasparov
la dic c'est absolument nulle moi j'ai
bien aimé cela se lit très bien
alors preuve la déteste c'est d'ailleurs
je les ai
battus il n'a pas sur
la bosse qui sont là depuis trop
longtemps après c'est pas ce qui vous
passionne au plus 1 malheureusement les
livres historiques
ce que j'en ai pas mal d très bon j'ai
le kasparov et karpov de team manager
fantastique
dont il y en a pas mal qui sont dans le
même style je peux pas tous les avoir
bien sûr mais celui-là bon serbe en fait
c'est juste parce que vlad a dit en
stream qui n'était pas bon et puis moi
je vais moi j'avais mes machines
si j'aime non
abbaoui à joueur d'échecs aussi de
maxime ah oui beau livre c'est encore
différent là ses petits frères
autobiographie
mais oui c'est bizarre prédécesseurs
j'ai jamais été traduit en français
d'ailleurs ouais c'est là peut-être qui
s est trop cher oui bien sûr ses droits
et sont peut-être trop cher et en plus
tu aurais pas un énorme non mais tu
aurais pas un énorme public ou un
message pour les échecs je trouve que
c'est très beau livre
aux joueurs d'échecs et vaut le coup
juste pour juste pour maxi jeu spore la
couverture
pour tous et la couverture aussi et la
couverture c'est le petit sacrifice
non c'est pas ça la phrase mais oui je
vois de quoi tu parles et mon livre ce
travail est plus de 1200 ouais ce sera
1200 1200 2000 on va dire et sera plus
un livre qui ce qui glisse quoi qui se
lit mes amis qui doit être en train de
suer en train de décrire mais
c'est un livre de stratégie où t'as pas
besoin d'un échiquier pour le lire un
peu des livres à l'ancienne qui sont
plus trop quoi et en avait il ya
quelqu'un qui parle des finales de ski
en français cela il était même moi je
les peluches et même pas où j'allais me
bon maintenant là on l'a en anglais
c'est déjà la cinquième ou cinquième
édition et à chaque fois il améliore en
fait ils m'ont dit dès qu'il trouve une
petite coquille dans le livre
il améliore
il est introuvable neige tentent
maintenant prend plutôt un
un power of tactique ou un blog alain
qui sont bien j'essaye
après moi j'ai flemme maintenant que
calculé par flemme de calculer si on
veut progresser à aimer je peux plus
progresser malgré le plus progressé
flemme mais il faut le faire
indispensable
weight vous étiez c'est vraiment faut
plus de 22 sinon vous allez vous perdre
et même mais c'est sympa je peux
regarder les marges qui trouvera pas les
exos les machins vêtu tu peux suivre
enfin tu vas trouver des trucs réseau
maintenant je les fais je me suis
vraiment
vraiment mis mal mais ça fait vraiment
progressé par contre
ça fait vraiment pas où et c'est bon
mais bon bref au serious man 2 sinon
faut pas rêver ce en finale à connaître
nantouar est-ce qu'il faut se faire
chier il est relou en or
insupportable bref il fit dans plus les
touch est nature
toys r us en finale mais après tu sens
la dif 1 par contre quand tu la fais le
toi redskins bah oui
comme ça tu commence un peu à quick de
trois pièces sur les bonnes cases
excusez moi messieurs 1
bon du coup on s'est perdu là parce que
c'est trop dur h4 alors s'il trouve hk
de cette fantastique ça peut être ça
c'est vraiment bon est ce que tu veux
pas que je vérifie en ce moment que la
logique chaque
même pour pour or regardez le temps
qu'ils arrivent
robo't a pas besoin de la turbine bas
qui je crois qu'il n'y a pas besoin tu
peux tout éteindre
hk fait mal
je vais aller ouvrir à non
faut pas jouer est roi
ces méchas
à
merci
hk talent
mais oui c'est alpha échec est
formidable à meilleurs sites
cheikh
meilleures boutiques des chèques de très
loin on va qui si vous avez besoin de
conseils en plus n'hésitez pas
quand même important de
trouver les livres bien non j'ai pas
c'est un peu la même chose bref
on n'a pas le winemaker
au méjan temps on entendu vlad on
entendu vlad est ce qu'on peut et est ce
qu on pourrait l'appeler avec avec son i
mode peut-être
c'est compliqué les échecs h4 ici je 4,5
et parce qu'il veut acheter en fait
est-ce que vlad peut trouver h4 ici je
me cachais tout ça
ils arrivent
ils arrivent on va le faire réfléchir un
peu sur sur cette position son ressenti
on va peut-être passer juste sur ali
reza est ce qu'il est toujours mieux qu
est en hausse et six bien joué ils
anticipent les d4
pourquoi il a joué cavalier acheteuse
il doit jouer pour d4 ici alireza
d'accord j'ai compris pourquoi il a joué
cavalier h2 il voulait peut-être pas
mettre la tour en 1 3 du coup pour
pouvoir jouer dame b 3
il va sûrement jouer un dame b 3 tours à
eux deux et des quatre
mais c'est pas ça c'est pas fait encore
la
misha j'attends vlad chevelu mais voilà
il mais j'attends vlad pour lui montrer
la position savoir ce qu'il veut jouer
dans la portée des carreaux s'y trouve
il trouve ses comptes en direct
la lettre forcé aulas attend ça c'est
intéressant ce qui fait c'est à double
tranchant mais c'est intéressant rien
[Musique]
et il a réussi à se débarrasser de son
mauvais fou quand même richard
c'est parce que je sais pas ce que ça
donne ouais pas facile là il s'en est
bien tiré comment il a fait
pourquoi il n'a pas joué d'un projet 5
kevin est ce que tu peux me
moi je préfère jouer pleutre éclairé
avec d'un projet 5
bat la plus belle bah oui oui madame
n'ai
toujours pas eu la rencontre
avec nikita
rencontre au sommet
donc ici
si je pensais plus à dame pranger 5e
qu'elle valait pranger 5 mais dans tous
les cas en fait après dun prendre
d'impro calais prend il veut h quatre
cavaliers h7 fourrage 3 dans la finale
je pense ça serait un petit peu mieux
pour
pour les noirs quand même mais là j'ai
moins en fait parce qu'il donne
l'activité un des pièces lourdes qui
vont taper sur le roi même si la
structure est mieux il ya quand même les
pièces lourd kit qui tape donc
position qui de re devient intéressante
et
anyresa ouais donc il va jouer dans b3
cessa d'un bep trois tours deux et il va
essayer de jouer des quatre
lamy son cavalier en âge de la
moins fan de cavaliers h 2 j'aimais bien
tour 3 en fait c'est le coup assez
habituel mais comme on a montré tout à
l'heure il y avait cette idée avec la f4
ok
on espère quelqu'un on va pas jouer
avant l'arrivée de l'arrivée
en colère ce drame il sanchez comme tu
peux déjà prendre
ses pas kevin et tactique j'imagine
car où il est parti sur son temps là ah
ouais il sait que c'est que la ccia
ouais il a le droit de se lever il sait
que c'est clutch la position donc il se
lève il a presque eu raison de perdre
cinq minutes comme ça au magnifique le
gotha le gotha qui arrive way you you et
le kof table
à l'heure alors ici n'est pas clair
encore les achats ouais ouais incroyable
hikaru fait en fait c'est toi qui les
entraîne donc cette fois d'entraîneur
secret
bizarre
bizarre mais je suis très impressionné
pour qu ils achètent et paris car ou en
général quand on
est ici très haut blanc alors si tu
trouves le coup tu joues le match contre
cliquant
le coup c'est le match contre le
tricolore il a dit d'accord ans kevin
bon
j'aurais dit alors rassurant on
parlerait prend une ou deux minutes à
temps mais juste ok je suis moins
nettement que soit je joue à tout aux
suisses ou un poteau français et ouais
je vais aller ont souvent un peu catin
soit 4
donc maintenant réfléchi d'accord oh bah
ouais je pense que c'est contenders
c'est contenders
mr bah ouais c'est sûr ah bah ouais en
fait c'est l'ado candidats ont trouvé
très bon va le faire rejouer on va faire
des routes de demain c'est trop 27,50
road to candidats
possibles 24,6 twh quatre noms mais 6 6
2 2 1 2 1 2 2
incroyable
tu joues le match du coup obligé le trop
fort boyard s'interrogent ils dans ce
coup là non bien sûr oui mais quand même
mais c'est encore un coup de plus tu
vois c'est moins fort que cali achats
moins dur
mais c'est quand même beau quel dommage
pour les noix kg et peut pas mettre deux
pieds sur trois volets social et que
malgré cet écueil il faut trouver
là on a trouvé le m d'ailleurs est ce
que par hasard là à la sortie de virtua
d'un dc c'est encore trois quatre coups
il n'a pas ou peu un truc avec les mots
non c'était même jusqu'à ce cap jusqu'à
ta part gardé leur équipe rapide je
parle des ajouts parle donne un
oui oui
donc où il faut bon droiture de rythme
oui bien sûr oui oui c'est 5,5
j'ai fait trop léger 3par dont vous
bougez et non oui non quand les poteaux
et page collège trois couches saint tout
de suite non c'était c'était près pas de
toute façon c'est ce que je me suis dit
oui et donc je me suis dis que j'ai pas
compris membres s'étaient préparés
jusqu'ici seul coup c'est 4 il n'a pas
trouvé non mais aux cavaliers h quatre
dames 5 fueg deux des huit mais très
bizarre food et un tas l'impression est
plus franche rigolade c'est ça ouais non
mais c'est dangereux ces quatre c'est
assez naturel quand même c'est pas été
d'accord qu'il faut peut-être cette
partie aujourd'hui comme nippone une
règle de cette partie on va jouer
énormément sur
mais c'est ce qu'on a dit c'est pas
celle là qui n'est pas
oui oui nakamura dépose c'était déjà la
partie
comme il a dit qu'à rouen
oui oui mais d'autres pas gagné c'est ce
qui fait là ça va faire la différence
alors aux proxys mois pas moins
les voiles c'est quoi maintenant dans la
position finale c'est
ce 0 25 12 25 mais c'est mais c'est plus
que 0 parfois parce que plus facile je
sais 0,25 en grosse profondeur à
au début c'est 0,50 plutôt oui en fait
y'a chlore
c'est la troisième ouverture ou jouent
alors envolé à l'issue rachat ou en a
assez vite soit nice d'offres
l'attaquant de 5 ans les bo3 parfois ils
voient souvent leur mort ils voient pas
dans dans par exemple dans des pots
firooz oui c'était pas une ligne youtube
c'est possible sinon donc les images
f3 petit rock faut 300 que les deux
connaissent et 6 253 le collège comme
c'est très souvent surgis - ici que ted
s'est révélé que plus bizarre
ça ne sert à rien que pour forcer les
noirs de redonner le contrôle de casino
mais après c'était pas complètement
obligé si tu peux aussi jouer par
exemple 3 sur france 3 il y avait
d'autres possibilités je pense que quand
il a joué fouet f2 j'ai dit tout de
suite hyper bizarre fief de nantes dont
il s'est passionné très bizarre pourquoi
et puis après quand j'ai vu cavalli a
changé trop fort ce que tu avais soir on
à schaffhouse hier soit cavaliers achats
cavalière de mais là il fait les deux en
même temps il pas très sain qui tape
d'être trop mal je pense qu'il ya et il
ya des types de joueurs comme est un
type de joueur qu'on
d'où bof on a comme moi que l'on ferait
eux ils voient une telle possibilité ils
vont quoi par contre également de type
de joueur qu'on wesley so ou et tiens au
nom pie
4 4 jouer jouer pépère les caue même
s'il voit de toute façon ne vont pas
faire
way up ouais mais après ils voient mais
il croit pas il faut le voir et y croise
oui
il ya un problème aux deux micros dans
mon cas ça ok non c'est moi moi
[Rires]
alors eh bien tu as bien joué là ouais
ça va mieux mais c'était je vais bientôt
te rattraper
je vais bientôt rattrapé j'ai ça y est
en tout cas pas facile de toute manière
collégiale telescope en anglais ça se
voit que la turquie peut me rattrape en
décidant de les attendre en balade c'est
jules il était à 68 et paix maintenant
oui oui bien sûr d'ailleurs je vous
mettais toujours en numéro 3 pts est
toujours numéro 3 française
en fait
il s'agit d'une part de parler
de moi que je vous ai je
pas mais ok tu trouves hk temps une
seconde pas facile quand même joli coup
non enfin prêt après 10 ans étienne ma
première proposition ouais je me suivra
peut-être il faut que tu montres
compréhension au but 4 d'ailleurs il n'a
pas joué ici avec b4 aussi qui était
intéressant donc je démontrais
ici tu vois ici b4 aux lettres ou f2
c'était pas mal parce que tu as raison
pour tu te tapes fin de t'empêches le
cavalier de j'ai quasiment pour tous
pour toute la partie
il a voulu aura absolument à se dépêcher
avec crème et c'est ce que j'ai dit
c'est que il règle les problèmes que ce
soit technique ou même en finale où tu
sais quand il est mieux y des problèmes
d'une manière
bizarre tant rapport aux autres oui moi
je les ai joué quelques fois j'ai vu
comment ils jouent techniquement enfin
quand je suis content imoca qui fait des
choses techniques
naturelles de la manière exotique c'est
ça parce que la cites si fouet f2 ou b 4
c'est à peu près le même niveau de coûts
un joker maxime il va jouer 4 4 4 et lui
trouve il trouve ce à quoi ils
soient pas de naturel et pas besoin je
veux dire quand des fois tu as besoin
auquel tu trouves mais quand t'as pas
besoin lui va quand même sur ce coup là
bas je suppose peut-être c'est aussi en
pensant que quand il est mieux que la
plupart des hôtes dans les yeux
exotiques ont ils cherchent à créer une
situation que ceux de viandes exotiques
ou peut-être qu'il pense même pas au cou
enfin pas en premier au cou naturel ou
plutôt juste que pour moi au wynn
naturel c'était ça ça va oui non mais
c'est ça c'est pas la même fin voit
souvent c'est comme ça je vais
et puis là il s'est barré en voyage
quand il est parti donc il est toujours
nettement mieux comme ça parce que quand
je suis parti c'était assez d'hôtesses
1h04
et en fait il a pris du temps pour les
coûts vraiment important en rien il a
réfléchi sur food et un fossé de aussi
un fichier de trois femmes trois quatre
minutes mais là je qu'attila présentant
fonds f2i il a pris du temps cavalier a
acheté un deux minutes
d'ailleurs je sais pas si vous oubliez
dit est très probablement oui mais pour
le spectateur et si jamais après vous
retrouverez sakho 16e coup en fait foi
de cette position avec 9 autres à forest
non il a joué ici tour à 2,8 à tour à
2,8 et après d'amr web 5 mai au lieu de
couper trois au web entre mata pas fait
t'as pas lu le cap non express ne jouit
pas du temps parce que avec les demandes
du shopping de la part de tout le monde
tout se joue court comme on mange de
shopping bah oui le doigt si ça ça et ça
parce que des soldes tout et je suis
donc je vois geoffrey janin van zyl pas
par jour rien que pour
du shopping et tu trouves h4 athènes
pour plus et en plus ce qu'on a eu et il
il refuse les cartes et russe à chaque
fois qu'il faut que je me promène avec
du plâtre du patron
[Rires]
oui oui elle m'a refusé ma carte jose
toute allure pourtant dans cette banque
la comme lieu de quoi ils m'ont dit ne
pas sanctionner ils m'ont assuré que ces
choix
ouais c'est pile à ces mêmes patrons en
fait c'est pas que patron des cours sont
un petit peu pas trop
gravement patronat
le plaisir
pas trop ce
[Rires]
qu'est donc h4 il va réfléchir là c'est
vrai qu'il faut trouver une version
10.5 mais plus tu te retrouves ta pas
envie de jouer h 50 ouais mais là c'est
trop dur en défense comme ça on va
laisser jouer son coup et
à j 4 c'est bien en fait il veut jouer
il veut déstabiliser la dame 1 il peut
faire h5
[Musique]
ou est ce qu'elle peut aller cette dame
/ hspa puis je suppose et vu comment
dire une fois la dame bouche de l'accord
j'ai vu absolument obtenir les cascades
pour le fou
couleur
rouge et quatre cd prochain coup c'est
peut-être pour ça qu'il va jouer cinq
lui même mais ça donne du dam g5 d'impro
pions prends ma page 5 g 6 oui hélas
faut trouver un coût pour les blancs
essayez d'installer un
jour il va mettre une pièce on est 6
même d'ailleurs peut-être cavaliers à 6
tours 8 qui a balayé ces cinq iata
preuve de adoré ça non
peut-être simplement cavaliers eux deux
c'est pas trop compliqué après il ya
d'autres coups sûrs h5 on n'est pas
obligé de jouer aux dames geste
est ce qu'on peut à terme en cavalier
non tu veux quoi sur h5 là je prends je
me suis plus de 5 comme ça que j'ai
juste fait un coup à la con qu elle ce
site
web mais tu menaces quoi je veux pas
facile rue 5
mais [ __ ] c'est pas possible
si c'est oui parce que tu veux pas fou
des quatre mais tu menaces cavaliers aux
5,6 à
lyon des idées c'était sirois bouge toi
le 5 2 5 a décollé de 7 que les six
enfants
trois bogeys
bon le seul problème c'est que le
football pas mais a d'ailleurs quand les
boues 93
parce qu'ici 2,5 g 4 sites ou protègent
au football collègues de re
par le cas d'un gpu six tours 5 à nankin
america ne peut pas où je peux
il ya du d4 aussi attention des quatre
albums
non mais c'est en fait c'est le seul
truc que j'aime pas trop c'est laisser
la casa
et lorsque leurs organes calculé qu'au
bout de trois faubourgs et qu'est ce que
ça donne d'opinion passé il ya cavaliers
prend des trois accords
c'est ok très très compliqué elles sont
bien que le gall
ça va être au coup par coup là mais h5
très logique un côté noir parce que si
tu sinon quoi sinon tu menaces h5n1 qui
ont réussi un simple jeu 4 1 pouces fait
remonter très vite et très désagréable à
jouer en plus
il va jouer cinq ou h 6 h cinq dames g5
mais ça serait pire
ouais bah je suis sage cinq dames g5 jeu
pendant six semaines pierre
pas rien que l'on peut prendre et valeo
6 les cavaliers proche des 5
mais je suis sûr qu'il ait la roue a
déjà ses réactions sur cette
attention quand même tu vois c'est pas
c'est pas complètement fini
ainsi ce matin
maintenant c'est pas mal oui mais si ça
m'a tout est incroyable
software 3 il ya vous ne savez pas parce
que rêve doué sur échec la faute
ok bon bah donkey h4 on s'attend h 5 on
voit pas vraiment d'autres
parcours 5
nonda match pardon
ouais mais je veux dire ça se regarde
c'est quand même assez haut mais change
c'est un coup quoi et a priori c'est
plutôt
h56 non non les blancs ils veulent pas
on a demandé la 1ee change de 2 des fous
de cases blanches en fait y aura pas d
change parce que le ce sur un coup on y
avec les blancs on va pas jouer fous ces
deux fonds prend des trois passes qui
auraient un pion
et
enfin y aura pas des changes doté
avantagerait plutôt les noirs pas cela
laisserait la case
de toute façon ouais si le fou noir il
avant lé là juste pour avoir des tours
et feint
d'avoir un cavalier ça serait ça serait
fantastique pour les noms des trois
c'est pas vraiment une question en fait
là on est pas on n'est pas là dessus et
bon enfin la position et là c'est que du
calcul de façon
et il en reste d'ailleurs pas beaucoup
du temps en famille puisqu'il reste
encore à faire 14 coup ouais et 14
compliqué
enfin n'importe qui est donc
attention et un projet
précis presse
alors c'est bizarre à gien ouais mais
pourquoi h4 je ne sais pas bizarre tu
vas y si
j'ai pas mal de fois ses positions
pourquoi faire cavalier h 2 alors qui
prendra jamais tu vas faire
j'ai plus l'impression qu'on doit
vraiment joué juste pour d4 et je suis
pas sûr que de jouer pour avancer le
pion h
profitable pour le vent mais pour que je
comprends mieux s'il fait au lieu de ça
des quatre tout de suite quoi l'érection
de noir il ya eu quatre là qui en l'air
ici ici et là où ici il faut des cadres
c'est quoi les réactions normalement
cette prise est là je pense déjà il ya
prise et tu peux prendre g45 des cinq
dessins en quête de 4,5 ou clairement
des cats
et aux cinq peut-être directement
non
gt4 jury courts en forme lan trois
formes et pourquoi tu jouer aux échecs
en fait
sortir ses coûts
ah ouais ça clique au hasard mais sa
quête d un chef laddh
sa clique trop bien pour pour arrêter de
jouer
des cats wisdom sd4 qu'on veut faire pas
parce que leur peut décéder kg 5 non
mais en fait c'est pour ça je pense que
ici je bouffe ouf
5 ici je sais j'ai cinq dames g4 ouais
je pense que c'est ça le rêve
dacquois là je mets des cats et c'est ça
qu'on veut ça explique alors sa volonté
de jouer comme les âges de
6 90 par contre moi j'avais tour 3
retrouver autour j'ai joué j'ai juste
beaucoup de fois c'est contre magnuson
et en général on fait tour 3 on a besoin
du cavalier pour jouer des quatre
domaines la pression donc j'avais de
proposer un plan comme ça kevin tour
trois dames ces 6es et un moment tour a
eu deux trois ou deux ça va jamais parce
qu'à cavaliers catéchèse
malheureusement parce que sinon c'est le
plus simple dames b3 et wade mais quand
même on peut jouer dans b3
tranquillement il n'y a jamais vraiment
dessin qui a jamais de quel projet 4es
et on va jouer peut-être même tour à
tour à voeuil de 4
alors alors doit-être qui doit garder la
dame en 17 mai
enfin bon moi je sais pas trop froisser
les coûts que j'avais quoi
déjà je pense que dans les parties de
1,1 pour se structurer à la tour est
toujours se retrouver ouais bah ouais tu
tiens f3 et le cavalier hyper bien
placés en fait froid
mais bon ok donc là il l'a fait parce
qu'il avait il a bien remis ces pièces
là tu vois c'était après je ne sais pas
si le jeu était optimale côté noir mais
beau mot changement de structure en fin
de il a bien avancé quoi mais là je suis
pas sûr que ça soit que h4 ce soit trop
profitable
peut-être peut-être
mais bon
c'est trop compliqué pardon et sinon
donc pour l'instant par des cats est pas
vraiment besoin pour l'instant rien
d'officiel donc on peut dire que la
phase de manioc pour ce que tu sais ça
y'a pas il ya encore quelques coups on
va pas trop pas trop comprendre ce qui
se passe donc il a toujours peur et il a
joué fabi
il a joué
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué cavalier c5
ok bon il tient la case aussi
donc il attend peut-être un peu plus
libre i sauf qu'après cinq de toute
manière il va jouer il va jouer h5 c'est
sûr alors il ya une idée derrière calais
c'est simple c'est que même le fou il va
pas bouger et la case elle arrivera pas
mais il peut avoir deux ou trois et
cavaliers aux 4 way c'est pour ça qu'ils
alors c est pour ça et aussi pour tenir
la case aux six en cas de h5 dame bouche
rouge et 4 donc ça a quand même le
cavalier est quand même mieux quand
bessette ou que les ondes dès 6 h 50
ouais mais acheter quoique bien sûr
nombreux livres et joel schalit est
intéressant où ils vont mettre sa dame
alors m6 des 6 bis
m6 j'aime pas trop parce que ça permet
fauché trois tout simplement et
cavaliers eve
a peut-être h5 dans ma vie c'est fou
j'ai 3 3 par exemple de 1.344
c'est comme ça peut-être adapter si
hockey compliqué
attendons
un prêt à j-5 de 9,6 à ce qu'on peut pas
jouer un coup comme dames 3 d'abord et
tous pensent que ce n'est pas d'insérer
un jeu des idées de jeu colicis
peut-être ouest 5 9 et 6 rouges et 3
cabrio si ce
n'est que quand il est remarqué
baptisant h5 dame m6 touché 4
la kf3 après
s'il n'y a pas trop de trois
comme le gâteau fosse 3 way
d'un fusil
non ok cavaliers c5 intéressant ça donne
cette idée de trois cavaliers au cat way
missclick on essaie de fait mais
j'essaye mais là c'est juste tellement
dur à
on va attendre quelques coups là
attendre quelques coups
non h5 pas tempo un tempo h5 parce que
il regarde ses lignes et là qu'on est en
train de regarder
c'est une nouvelle idée
33.4 caïds et 3 ou trois cavaliers ou 4
c'est une nouvelle idée implanté
par fabi bah oui s'il peut plus se
permettre ce qu'ils subirent me concerne
pour
vous gâcher un avantage aussi que dans
un coin ouais normal on sent que c'est
bien pour les bleus
mais ça va vite les pièces elles sont
quand même activant les pièces je pense
qu'on serait pas très bien nous
on serait comme partie le père soffo
bien sûr
[Rires]
parler de toi
est ce que ça a été il a joué mais j'ai
pas le coup là le coup n'est pas arrivé
chez moi
non
de jouer quoi tout le monde est d'accord
je n'ai pas nagé pas le
bon ton pied
et ça a joué mbow chef habile à jouer
quoi
d'amd 6 ok ouais vous le voyez mais moi
je n'ai en tout petit l'échiquier en
fait du coup on est jamais à la main
l'allée des coûts n'arrive pas n'hésitez
pas à le mettre
des coups n'arrive pas il a joué dam des
6es sur
fouquet ouais ouais ouais dur
g3 il veut faire tout répond
oui sans aucun doute mais par exemple
non
non ça
[Musique]
voilà ça c'est un coût d'un coup de son
aréna
ouais tu disais à 52,6 faucheux trois
tours et
oui c'est un bug donc alors il faut que
je mette les coups alors
donc h5 dam des six
alors fouillé 3 c'est ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure avec kevin c'est que ici
attention à pas jouer tout reprend ça
c'est important autour prend même le m
ça c'est bien hop il ya des coups comme
ça avoir pas facile ces chèques pas
facile mais surtout réforme peut jouer
ou hd
est ici là peut-être le fort damage this
way il a peut-être le fort d'un match 6
pas clair ça peut être
mais ouais là on donne on donne de
l'activité un peu pour rien par exemple
des attaques et il arrive là c'est pas
clair on adore je vois pas bougé trois
jours où je donne donc tu votes rouges
est fou g4 d'abord peut-être fou j'ai
trop après mais ici c'est trois
là qu à regarder je bouffe dans quand
joe cada fois
enfouies si je pendant un à dix grammes
et wilding frau
ouais donc fou g4 et là il veut quoi
alors est-ce qu'il a joué un vga ok ça
revient il a joué fou gk t il c'est andy
les paroles de marseille arrivé parti
n'est parti quoi qu'est ce qui se passe
est grave pour coter en tête passer au
dessus tout à poser ton adversaire tu te
promènes c'est la pire des choses en
plus si je tous les meilleurs coups il
te revois tempo tenue jeudi encore cette
année tu as encore ça encore loupé quoi
c'est d'ailleurs à
la quatrième fois déjà deux au canada
les candidats beaucoup joué 4 il a joué
quand cariat qui n'a gagné
2016 oui
oui
ouais mais on sent qu'il est il est
moins fort dans ses positions là qu'il
ya quatre ans avec les susurre compliqué
comme ça
à chaud un vrai dire je n'aime pas trop
cette décision premièrement à nous
montrer cette ligne contre lac saint
louis puis delajoux et vêtements puis
elle a joué contre nous en fait tous les
trois phases tout cette décision''
bizarre mots pour espoir non je suis
d'accord tu as joué le jeu et tu leur
montrerai pas dans ce cas l'air dans ce
tournoi il y en que tu joues parent dont
tu t'en fais ou le monde le sait
ouais bah là on voit qu'il arrive est
extrêmement préparé qui rouvre un qui
bossent pour icare ou alors ton avis
écoute j'aimerais appris que quelqu'un
bouge pour eux à part deux fameux la
méthode c'est pas des little john howe
emails etc et c'est à nice c'est vichy
c'est un gars ils reculent même
franchement rouquine je sais pas les
gars sur cette durée à sa puanteur des
rivières mais le problème ce qui est un
grand problème et je m'excuse d'après
les spectateurs à sais pas qu'est ce que
vous regardez maintenant
soyons réalistes parce que oui non mais
de façon ça doit pas être garé parce que
là il a d'autres choses oui j'y vais par
ci par là mais je veux dire dans le
niveau éventuellement possible mais ça
peut d'azur joue ici pour pêcher le bon
sens où ça que je cherchais pas inventé
ça peut être karlsson
[Rires]
franchir
pour des intrigues
cornetto
encore les causes cachées quoi
aulas il ya des gaffes de partout on va
les voir quand même parce qu'il n'est
pas bien il est pas bien faby là non ça
c'est là c'est critique je critique
c'est pas voir juste d'être foutu
positionnement mais incroyable à partir
de yahoo et la prépa et les coûts voilà
c'est trop c'est trop c'est au dessus
et malheureusement ça peut mettre fin
aux chances de fabi et peut-être même du
caire où la place est pauvre ce que là
demain pour que fabi bat n'est pas ça va
être dur
après une partie pareil quoi qu'il a
vraiment plus le choix donc
à vrai dire pour moi qu'est que ce soit
cependant pas nouveau peu importe qui
m'opposait
ouais ouais je sais que tu étais pas que
tu aimais pas son jeu moi j'ai baisé
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans
celle là ouais ça continue les
manoeuvres
[Musique]
quatre cavaliers voilà à la toile pour
toi tu l'approché des taux long terme
louvre ouais bah ouais mais là tu donnes
qui aimerait leur dit qu'ils donnent
bizarre quand même ouais mais bon avec
cavaliers proches compliqué
mais là non
ok moi écouter complet ça marche ça n'a
jamais marché dans ce parti là pendant
d'un coup ça marche souvent les joueurs
ou pss ouais mais là je pense qu'ils
jouent un peu des coûts un peu au hasard
de toute façon
assez mieux avec le cavaliere f3 tour 3
ses cavaliers f3 mais n'empêche je vois
route mais
il voit bah oui c'est comme ça qu'on
pousse ils voient ils voile mais le
problème c'est que maintenant sur
cavaliers un coup comme qui a valu six
hockey
compliqué de façon c'est parti
compliqué est ici un petit chèque vite
fait
oula bizarre bizarre j'ai dit quoi tout
à l'heure que les crayats non mais
pourquoi ici pourquoi pas jouer terme
projet
pourquoi tu as envie de jouer cavalier
tron non jugé lundi de bouffon ouais
mais avec quoi avec d'or oui bah oui
tempo quoi pourquoi se faire mater quoi
il est prévu que presque rien parce
qu'elle attire la turbine est elle donne
équivalent qui va déprendre d'impro ok
tout de suite mais nous on prend quoi
mieux
qu'elle pourquoi ouais pourquoi parce
que là tu donnes tout rejet un tour f1
d'alger 3 tu as tout la taxe sur le roi
et
là je vais pas vous mentir
je souhaite pas vous mentir mais pour
alain roy gien damage 4 même tour à 2,7
pour quoi en fait comme vous le voyez à
des fins de le protéger
c'est très bizarre et des coûts un
bizarre bizarre ils ont pas peur ils ont
pas peur mais ce feu à la fin ils seront
matés quand même au caire menace à tour
sur scène les levures 5
pourquoi il a fait du coup ça je ne sais
pas quoi les beats du coup les amis est
de nous s'il vous plaît pas mais pas
assez fort pour du piper
et vois tu le maïs il faudra courir pour
l'occasion sept pour jouer
comme ça il a juste en poney le connaît
le mieux sur le destin de son père au
salon ferme quand ils l'enferment pour
faire marquer le triste je suis où je
comprenne je sais pas si c'est approprié
1 2 3 et ainsi passer c'est si bon non
c'est dur c'est bizarre là enfin tous
ces coûts sont bizarres juste tu peux
jouer d'un projet 5 avoir une finale
même si c'est pas nettement mieux
mais on a quand même ok je pense qu'il
n'avait pas envie de laisser h 4 x 3
comme il est c'est ce qu'ils voulaient
faire richard c'est sûr
mais ici on a quand même quête à une
finale un peu de chair d'ailleurs ça
ressemble à la partie d'alireza par
exemple est-ce qu'on peut pas jouer
juste comme ça roy fuite rejouer sens
des fins
tranquillement tout autant il
abat non c'est juste ça peut être juste
un tout petit peu mieux ou égal mais
plutôt tu bouges impliquant le 2 2 en
valeur et ce dès et un pouce sur la
pierre à lire et écrire et sur ceux de
déposer pour les spectateurs
qu'est ce que je vais savourer tout
c'est ce qui me rappelle c'est me
rappelle qu au début de sa carrière en
tant que joueur dit christophe a eu
beaucoup de mal contre siens et il était
allé demander à ce parce qu'ils sont
conseil vous avez gagné moi je compte
heureux qu est ce que vous avez contre
et les guides ou c'est en fait très
simple il faut jamais oublier trop vite
il faut attaquer au rendement dans ce
cas là il sait pas comment ces deux
femmes il trouvera des problèmes humains
donc peut-être doute à un joueur
brillant de livrer un match dur et très
bien se défendre contre les attaques
vite - contre attaques comme ça a
déclaré m
ok on va vite on revient sur fabi qui a
joué
qu'est-ce qui nous a trouvés sur fiat
j'aime aller au bout
il a joué h6
hockey à vrai dire les symboles pas une
grosse tribulations quoi toi un moment
ça se tient quand même ce qui fait
plutôt terne le terme est terrible pour
les catégories à b
b 4 pas mal aux moines sont logés tous
les cas tu pas mal mais bekkat peut-être
que tu donnes du e3
s'affaiblissent et trois
des quatre trois d'entre eux trois
cavalières 4 précise encore
[Rires]
écrasé gueule d'abord c'est toujours
moins non madame en toile
ahmed du coup b4 ça devient joli mais ça
devient très jolie b4
parce que si tu dois jouer c'est bab
ouais moi que tu lui as a way ses
patients en fait est ce que c'est une
avancée quand bkc bab à tu veux tu veux
bkt faut aussi
joli
nom mais juste un an wannian locaux
voyaient tous eu cinq pas que faut aussi
je veux oublier les menaces je pourrais
que kovalev au service de trois jours
non mais sur le chat est jeune il va
prendre quand même
je veux en courbe et que j'ai droit à 7
h 8 wyser pratte brigade cavaliers à 4
15 et 4 quand même prend la 4 4
après quoi donc
après quoi
après après quoi a été ingéré comme les
u6 de revues de couvrir 50 en moyenne tu
vois me donner
un
touriste un cavalier pca
alors attends revient
compliqué alors b4 comprend et on prend
trois fuites il doit regarder ça
j'imagine
cb4 on a envie
b4 encore
cavaliers à 4 obligé étudie cavaliers
aussi stable à tour
ok
toi
ça a été jouée est sur b4 en fait
l'ordinaire cavaliers des as et dong
avait laissé la main sur 5 à 4 après oui
d'accord c'est une autre chose et c'est
pas clair non plus les b 4e intéressant
mais
dans mes trois dames et trois non mais
c'est bien sûr une autre possibilité est
ajouté m cathy joue la finale en fait
bizarre en fait je jouais de jouer pour
la finale
alors
là on a envie de dame prend tout reprend
fouet 6
voire bouge faut prendre des 5 tu vois
bouffe rire
il faut pas qu'ils aient un bon coup
noir de trois tours
3,3
d'un printemps reprend x 6 donc si il
faut déjà expliqué que cavalier projet
600 ch est way qui va les prendre s'ils
ressemblent
ressembla finito
comprend peut-être
pas facile à jouer dont crois je suis tu
es ici pourquoi on peut pas prendre on
pourrait pas prendre un des cinq
shows
joost on peut prendre
chaud ça va être difficile pour
après c'est pas le meilleur des pions
quand même mais c'est un pion n'empêche
il peut avoir d'autres possibilités mais
il ya d'autres possibilités mais ça
c'est le plus au bios mais bon comme
comme on dit ici il ya un coude un coup
de turbines qui est très dur c'est faux
il semble finalement un vieux matériaux
qui ont touché quatre insurgés trois
noms ouais mais tu veux m
oui oui l'opinion sur gba toi et c'est
fini tu fermes si tu fermes mais il est
obligé donc ça c'est obliger les ou
feint de bouffe on bouffe
il bouffe on bouffe il bouffe
et les joues ce mois le positionnement
très donc il ya trois pions là c'est
beaucoup sauf le total sur les casemates
et même les mêmes ici pour l'enfermer
ça ressemble oui et positionner le mas
est en fait et c'est probable c'est
probable qu'ils jouent faux f5 hikaru
dans son style d'ailleurs ils purent
peut-être même au jeu dans la cathédrale
et maintenant phelps ce qui peut-être
ouais mais la finale elle est peut-être
way aussi ok well as donc là en fait il
réfléchit d'ailleurs il peut même faire
ça au haut
à oui voila je ne reconnais et si elle a
réussi un petit chef vérité et ça va
être hyper raconte le père roy croit
plusieurs choses méchantes jamais lyon
c'est le style
[Rires]
ouais ok bon bah là en fait c'est sûr
qu'il ya un énorme avantage
après regarde fabi la puck neuf minutes
en fait un bond à moins pas d'un manque
beaucoup et ça mais il est clair qu'il
va gagner ça c'est évident donc ça sera
donc n'est pas plus 4 carmona plus de
naka plus
environ voient peut-être écoute on peut
là comme il réfléchit en gardant en
grand écran
on garde n'a qu'à on pourrait presque le
même temps grand écran maca
ah oui cette partie tour 7la y réfléchit
bret la partie la partie de
foot aiment bien ici
ouais ouais
ouais après ça fait toujours un peu peur
avec les blancs parce que
tu peut louper une tactique
d'ailleurs j'ai une question pour vous
pouvez communiquer avec moi je bois du
courrier scott une fois qu'à montrer
j'ai compris que je veux sa deuxième
principe a dit moir comme toi tu es très
expérimentées ici quand les 6 gr il ya
deux raisons pourquoi
bah oui
avec bon le truc c'est que qu'allié f6
gf là ça se calcule ses cinq
balles de set dont les pièces qu'elles
sont mal qu on classe et donc quand même
probablement pas gf à cause du h5n1
tempo rien que même pour jouer d'un
budget celle des
recettes
mais là a priori cavaliers pros f6 il
doit jouer pour prendre 6 h cinq
cavaliers sept cavaliers h4
tu me diras même ça ok 12 juin wilson
est ce que c'est la fin du monde bah
ouais tu attaques vite le roi blanc
aussi torje huit tours fc qu'un peu
comme dans la partie ii de richard on
arrive vite à l'attaqué mais oui en fait
ici faut que je peux parier il va pas
faire cavaler fh d'eau et notre foi
après je pense après il peut jouer deux
décades peut-être ici cet objet cette
dame g7 suivie de f5 compliqué cavaliere
est très dur c'est dur à jouer sa
position
d'un prof 4 2 n'a qu'a finalement un peu
attaquées et beaucoup plus tard été
attaqué c'est ça
qu'on va rester plutôt ici il a fait
encore autrement il affirme qu jolie
aussi
finalement il ajoute simple nadia ils
jouent très très sain cavaliers pros
faut prendre wabush faut prendre des
cinq
mais je préfère trop simple je préfère
quand même les autres solutions je pense
qu'il s'est passé gourmand quoi oui
c'est ça va être quand même plus facile
de jeu ça pour les noirs je pense que
oui parce qu'après même alors le sol ce
que ce qu'on aime enfin moi ce que
j'aime pas trop et j'imagine l'ado si
c'est que ici même ce genre de finale
ça va pas être si facile
parce qu'on n'a pas vraiment de bonnes
pièces de vin ou de mauvaise pioche
adversaire m donc c'est pour ça en fait
que c'est probablement pas la rouquine
l'horizon pas pris ça réfléchit après
y'a pas d'autres coups un autre projet 4
les premières fuites top 5
on obligé de prendre la fuite mais ça
laisse des chances il est possible aussi
les aime que nous n'oublions pas il a
presque joué kyo les tournois en ligne
depuis deux ans peut-être assez
instinctive quelqu'un qui ceux qui
jouent en blitz un vie des gens plus
facile la joue quoi parce que je sais
que c'est gravement à présent je me
relève bas et skis et alain problème ce
que j'aime pas trop c'est qu'il avait 55
minutes aussi il a même pas cinq minutes
pour cette position presque gagnante et
tient à les regarder deux versions
différentes d'où l'idée foot 55 ans et
ça se voyait que vous avez fait ça c'est
vrai que c'était kanyenda les deux et
je pense que les gens seront prêts ça
parce que visibly moi ça donne plus que
ça car il a joué très vite soit on
regarde pourquoi tu as 55 minutes cinq
minutes alors c'est quasiment
c'était quasiment fini là il ya des il
ya des chances un pur fabi tour f5 il
veut quoi je vous presse à gerzat
content s'il y aura des sciences pour
bien je serai content
après vu la différence de temps c'est
probable qu'il la gagne il a joué tour 8
f 16
là c'est pas
bizarre là bizarre bizarre de laisser la
tour f 4 comme ça un peu tout seul
bizarre j'aime pas d'accord maintenant
ils bougent sont fous
alors il surtout rage 5
alors s'il faut et roya tour eiffe un
échec savary bouche sont fous je veux
dire oui c'est quelque part
donc tout reste 5 et qu'est-ce qui se
passe
bon ok pourquoi pas des tours aux cinq
mois que tu vois à toulouse non y'a tout
raconte monastère prochain je trouve la
manade un contact
allégé 3% question bouffe
ça quand même l'air
[Musique]
si bouge aïe la tour f 6 peut-être
cépage par principe j'aime pas la sete
mais bon c'est pas mal en fait il veut
tout rejet 4 c'est pas
ok moi je voyais plutôt une défense avec
en lâchant le pion au 4 mai
[Musique]
mais fabriquer un peu gourmand
les dons
donc il vous reste à sept minutes et
demie pour faire
pour faire
si
b 7 ça va être jouée à 5 ça va être joué
on peut toujours pas bouger le vrai
c'est pas clair là en fait bien jouer le
tour huit f5 de
bon après on est en wave c'est vraiment
ça vient d'où ça vient d'eux
caro12 toute façon grosse faute à tout à
l'heure
oui oui comme la faute parce qu'un peu
plus dire que c'est c'est sûr que c'est
grillé c'est plus sûr après c'est
probablement mieux quand même
j'ai 5
ok on arrive quand même avec les pièces
mais pas sûr pas sûr parce que
maintenant il ya quand même il n'y a
plus que il ya deux pions pour la
qualité déjà
oui parce qu'ils les pièces sont ni
pires depuis que jamais dans cette
partie mais
ouais là on n'arrive pas à un duo matos
et on tient plus la pièce
non mais on essaie de les replacer quoi
mais on a quand même un cavalier en h1
c'est pas
qu'il a joués pouces et 6 il n'a pas
joué ou b 7e opus et 6 ok et après tout
reproche cinq ans dans la sombre devient
serbie came mais qu'est ce que c'est que
ça mais il est fou il voit tout
récemment encore deux ou trois coups et
c'est encore deux trois coups il va
perdre en fait
est que si on va se dire [ __ ] qui est
ce qui se prépare est quoi
certes à rien
phoceis et le meilleur coup peut-être un
mur commun comprend pas pourquoi alors
parce que peut-être les murs commun et
pourquoi
expliquez nous faut des quatre cavaliers
qu'elle sait pas c'est trop s'est pas
assez naturel et sait pas on sait pas
mais peut-être
mais même si tu récupères ans oui ça
joue au hockey au prince le jeu
peut-être
qu'il est pro katia tour f1 qui va taper
b2 donc
ça ok tour huit en un cavalier g5
ça si vous passez sur sagan ok on a vu
pire que ça on a vu pire que ça va
nettement à culoz
mieux pour le blanc et qu'est-ce qui
trouvera ce qu'est ce que tu penses que
ta view
sainti et expérimenté expérience et à
fabien il est bien dans la défense d'une
telle pose
là bas il va s'accrocher ça c'est sûr
moi ce que je suis mais reculer bien
quand elle s'accroche d'habitude au
prétoire
pas sur blessure
c'est pour ça que façon
pas son point le plus fort c'est ça il a
joué fou des cats
mais bon ça va être ça qu'à tours f5
cavalière de tour bouge il va jouer il
faut prendre
ok il est tellement contentes de
souffler avec cbs
finalement
qu'il compte plus les pions là
alors voilà c'est la raison pas
ouais c'est du
je pensais du 35 % de victoires 40%
peut-être 55 entre victoire et défaite
mais pas pas plus que ça bon à vrai dire
plutôt léger rictus 50 50 tant que ça ok
mais pas sur
moi mais way s'en va il s'en fout il
s'en va
mais il a donné la vie facile à
fabriquer la poker même avec cinq
minutes il peut faire facilement mon nom
au plus haut plus que vrai qu'il n'ya
pas de piège qu'ils vendent peu tendre
oui il va juste ok finir les coups il
est urgent en or - 1 - 0 2 me
ouais on peut estimer
alors normalement au final même une cale
une tour epyon contre deux pièces c'est
quasiment équivalent mais là on a le fou
en d4 qui est extrêmement bien placé et
qui donne c'est plutôt sain pour les
blancs grâce à grâce à ce fou imaginé
une structure à cette v6 c5 un fou alors
plutôt joué deux trois coups comme ça
en fait là les blancs ils sont mieux
vraiment grâce à ce faux bond et à cette
tactique aussi il n'y a pas de recette
ou deux tours 8 kg cinq échecs
mais si on décale se fout en f2 et les
pions à 7 b 6 et 5 c'est juste pas mieux
pour le avec le cavaliere f3 fouet je
sais juste pas mieux peut-être même plus
facile pour les noirs
mais la grâce à cette case quand même
mieux pour le mans foot mais il
il compte sur cette case depuis qu'il a
trouvé ce concept eco les achats ouais
mais là un bon elle tout à l'heure ça
contrôler l option des cinq le pion aux
quatre maintenance contrôle plus grand
chose en fait c'est une belle pièce mais
c'est moins
moins spectaculaire que
au bac et vinyle est parti il est parti
de chez lui
sans qu'il en soit une chose de
couverture vous inquiétez pas qu'ils
viennent vous allez le renvoi voir parce
que la partie sera long je sais pas par
rapport aux autres cette partie sera
très longue
je préviens dingue or d'autres
va être longue mais pas sur
les belles c'est un peu le moment clé du
tournoi un peu à l'instar de la septième
partie
carlson n'est pas
c'est une partie pour notre pour karman
a en tout cas c'est à ce niveau là
d'ailleurs qu'est-ce qu'il doit détester
depuis pas mal de coups déjà s'en fout
sur 2,3 je parle de corona
mais là il sait qui est qui va partir ce
faisant
vous savez ça peut être traumatisant
parfois quand vous souffrez avec un
talent fou sur de toi
l'autre partie vous pouvez avoir le
monde fou et là il peut être bien moins
vous éviter parce que vous étiez trop
traumatisés ouais alors ses rives non
mais c'est ça qui est incroyable c'est
que le fouquet sur détroit depuis le
début on fait qu'il est mauvais oui
heureusement auquel son seul avantage
c'est le tour et fin d'autant moins
malheureuse massat rouge voudrait alors
en bessette il aurait été beaucoup mieux
tout ou n'importe où en fait non des
trois îles étaient terribles prendre il
prend la case du cavalier les pièces
blanches qui tourne autour
mais là il va s'en débarrasser comme
etienne a dit guillaume et lyon
la position du fou sur des quatre change
et l'évolution de cette position est
pareille aurait pu être si c'était pas
aller au fond noir surtout trois
cavaliers de trois là serait retourné
l'évolution marc mayor de noix
la même manière il ya des cases ça
dépend des pièces qui les occupants
ouais donc
d'habitude bien sûr la bonne case celle
qui prend des parts votre pion ou vos
pions et peut pas être touché par les
pionnières et qui ont même temps control
point des cases importante c'est ça
c'est la définition du ski et une pièce
forte
dominante ici de 4 défendez-vous deux
attaques de cette plus value pour le
puits on se croit donc les a donc
soutien à la sortie du courrier paris
faisait aussi je ne puisse être
contrôlée elle dame océans à l'est de
damas les a5 bécade du coup ça va
affaiblir willis les pions noirs lors
des quatre incroyable
il est possible que
notre moi est en train de comprendre
qu'est ce qu'il a fait avec ce moment là
on n'est pas au niveau de plus donner
plus haut niveau de
plus 150 même pas mais pas comme ça il
va rester très peu de pièces sur
l'échiquier
cdu +1 un peu plus mais peut-être pas
suffisant très souvent très souvent
insuffisants vous terminé la partie avec
tours cavaliers contre tours autour fou
contre tout rond malgré un + 3 c'est pas
suffisant
et on parle pas encore de forteresse
ouais non mes
notes d'été tu dois pas être
moins qu'ils aient une grosse tactique
là
ça peut être du plus de 50 ans à moins
d'une grosse tactique on vois pas à part
qu'est ce ça
on peut essayer de
je vois pas comment on peut avoir mieux
que qu'un moment fonds propres ont gagné
3,15
bas mais je pense que c'est normal ça
sera le mieux je vois pas comment
pascal rivet spears ici ont fait
cavaliers prend il y aura du tour et
feintes autant on n'aura pas mieux
on aura pas mieux
c'est moi ou qui viennent bordier a
changé d'autres têtes c'est vous
ah ouais mais si c'est possible un coup
en profondeur 51e trouve plus trois mais
ça veut dire qu'il ya une grosse
tactique ici et qui a l'air très très
dur
à trouver je vois
difficile
là on estime en fait on estime cette
position
celle là qui paraît la plus logique
naturelle
ça ressemble à 50 50 % de chances de
gagner ça
quand même 50 de gagner parce que j'ai
trop fort ce fou on va quand même
attaqué ouais ça va vite quand même
qu'elle est enfin
c'est dur à jouer en tout cas c'est
encore les c5 tourer c'était faut
trouver quelque chose qu on tombait
donc peut-être info jouer à leur tour
windows 7 je prends 5 à 5 mètres le tour
donc comme ça comme ça
mais c'est vrai que ça peut être presque
gagnant pour le blanc en fait ça va vite
tu arrives avec tour sans faim tu as
quand même beaucoup de calme le fou des
cats et qu'un monstrueux et citait ma
famille au nom de tous alors ouais
euh pardon ah oui c'était plus logique
que l'état raison plus logique un
[Musique]
jeu qui est sûr qu'on laisse aux cinq as
qui est d'ailleurs toujours 6e possible
et rocky joie
ouais mais regarde qui a valu aux six
cavaliers fuite aussi
ça va vite quand même c'est fort quand
même c'est fort
c'est fort
ok mais c'est pas facile facile
attendons
il réfléchit également
d'autres font monter des jours
donc oui il peut réfléchir un moment où
plus ils essaient de trouver mieux en
fait que ce que cette finale
annoncée il a joué cavalier hadjaoui
ccsa rock et rock et d'enluminure donc
un peu plus tard oui ça va se répéter
encore
mais comme ça elle est sûre que doit-on
va pas bouffer sur m6 par le bio parce
que d'abord celle
d'un f3 il veut stopper à six parce qu
on veut tous les français c'est la
profondeur du truc j'imagine mais bon
oui d'accord
[Musique]
ouais
je pense que jamais dans l'histoire de
cette petite variante les besoins donc
je mens obtenu position c'est une
position aussi bon
parce qu'en plus avec la tour en justice
quand tu vas mettre la dame en vain
qu'il ya plus droit fuite ça c'est
important souvent là le roi il va il va
courir il devait atterrir tôt sur
justice ait pu courir avec une fois
réglé le problème pardon
par exemple un coup
bon peu importe
je voulais pas m dames aussi parce que
c'était pas ça le sera dans un truc
comme ça le roi il parle jamais des
kairouanais fuite il ya du d'un projet 6
c'est pour ça qu'il a joué de la f3 il
pouvait d'ailleurs commencé par touré
fin
bizarre de f3 pourquoi pas tour f1 est
dommage qu adam est très très bizarre le
logique de jouer tour et fort
oui j'ai lutté une grande tournée du
spectacle
vivant un peu désappointé emilio botin
peut-être elle a voulu jouer dans les
six après dans votre gergy vous invite
pour jeannot toujours huit mois
c'est roy bourgeois h en dérogeant ainsi
rois as schmitt waha chanel pour achat
je vous montre la variante de vlad mais
c'est en 3g parfois régler
mais ça sert à rien parce que tu sais je
sais qu'au fond rien n'a ni besoin
est ce que ça marche bref 8
ça marche pas frustrant
au dam des soldats morts oui mais c'est
parce que tu as fait faux de cet âge à
moscou de la partie
je fais 5
[Rires]
c'est pas possible
trop de shopping vlad trop fort
trop fort
ok donc
ouais il fait j'aimerais mais ça paie
ouais bon peu importe ils en sont où là
ça réfléchit
ok
donc il a fait g6
il a joué g6
alors pourquoi je vous vois
c'est compliqué mais il veut jouer il
veut jouer tour 6 3 g 7 tours achoui est
en fait maintenant
d'accord je joue tout rachat
selon le plan général
je joue aux gens
et je sais rien
ok il a joué tu auras chien il a trouvé
web ont pas très dur
il faut dire il faut dire pas très dur
bizarre non pas le jeu ne pourra que
c'est le jeu d'houdain les dix derniers
coups
là on peut je sais pas si c'est pas son
niveau à
marieville a touché les questions de la
canicule et madrid 2 1 pour les polonais
oui d'accord enfin bon c'est climatisé
quand même j'imagine la pologne je vous
rappel c'est un prix des forêts
il faut jamais trop trop chaud
dans ces cas là tu auras 1,7 g 6
peut-être c'est le prix nobel du pire
des candidats
parce que c'est nous qui avons cru de la
giclais aucune cohérence non c'est
bizarre c'est bizarre joue tellement
bien parfois que là c'est surprenant
d'avoir quand même
25 à madrid
attention un pas deux pas de fausses
infos
juste à temps pour lui ces deux canicule
comme dans bizarre bizarre non mais en
plus cela il est pas trop stressé
donc c'est quand même je sais pas j'ai
pas de ces surprenants que tour à trois
aussi c'est surprenant
bizarre aussi il arrive passe un truc là
madrid j'ai bien comment les spectateurs
sur ces chiens sont toujours très
scrupuleux suis dit il faut il faut
souvent marie tout tu peux être sûr que
cambrai vérifier point soit maintenant
mais ils sont et on a quand même à mais
ça fait une semaine qu'il fait 25
possibles
aujourd'hui voilà deux parties ça c'est
une partie bizarre vous laissez passer
pour ça que je joue critiquer
je casse mais les hausses très souvent
quand quelqu'un fouille les décisions
conseil de celles de la camorra et
quelques coups et très vite et après
s'est mis à réfléchir je lui dis
toujours mais avant de prendre cette
décision très très
importante très important il a fallu
calculer il ya quinze minutes il a fallu
calculer cette position des positions
non pas maintenant pris maintenant
qu'est ce que quelqu'un les faubourgs
fausses et plus encore
non là on a mais bon là c'est quand même
du très très haut niveau cette partie
hikaru fabiano
oui c'est sûrement la partie du jour
mais ça avance d'accord ça jouer
cavalier f2 tour eiffe set
il a joué b4
et ouais on nous dira un b 4 ok il a pas
pris e 4
bizarre encore très bizarre et très
soupçonnant
3 on ne peut pas beaucoup avec la tour
vous trois tours sept
cavaliers d
faute d'autres renvois au moyeu fou
n'est plus sûre d'elle
à une porte d'entrée quand même
qu'il a une porte d'entrée après tout
reste six fois f3
g5 et
même ses bab danse et bab
bekaert intéressant il lâche 5 il a joué
ok je 5 je sens qu'à côté
je sens qu'ils souhaitent alerter plus
ça peut être très glissant parce que je
sens que c'est une case noire ils
s'élèveront qui on se fout une fois il
quand les banques vont attaquer avec
lecavalier le fouet la tour
impossible que c'est un traître reagan
affaiblissement
5 dangereux
s'il faut prendre ou quatre fois quatre
colocataires et noir jouent autour de
400 jours à jean dauger quatre là
les c5 bourgis
l'aï à
203,5
et l et es et h5n1
non mais là c'est fini tôt c'est sur
cinq c'est c'était soit puis on prend
mes 3 soit 3 peut-être que les deux
étaient mauvais
fait peut-être que p4 c'est sympa comme
coup parce qu'ils
s'y compte et bloque le pion à 6 je suis
content que je t'ai demandé est ce que
free rebond de la défense dépose parce
que tu m'as fait comprendre que tu ne
penses pas il paraît que oui avec raison
c'est dur pour tout le monde en défense
c'est très bien qu'il ya des gens qui
comptent et qui sert chirchir xichang
8,3 encore non donc il faut que mon
poids je monte pas réfléchi sur est
plutôt salée rld est ici salaire mérité
sur mon point le pion à si cela qui est
menaces kg 5 machin tour j'ai quatre
cavaliers ses 5
on tour à sète on regarde pas on sait
que ça va être perdant donc j'ai six
tours 5 et
h45 il a pas de vrai
c'est probablement faut prendre quatre
cents coups faciles après il ya
peut-être eu huit ya peut-être fou
dessins qu'il ya peut-être des coûts
même et h5 c'est sûr et
vous savez ce moment-là peut-être
horrible pour les ai laissés content
qu'ils ont pris part est peut-être un
petit truc pour pousser contre les
petites robes de les premiers chi demain
et maintenant il va perdre sa partie
contre nakamura il va au tournage où il
va dire que ce que loose longue préparés
ils ont préparé bruit pour le
sympathique de demain n'est pas
suffisamment compétitifs c'est terrible
il faut trouver un truc plus compliqué
et ça c'est le pire pour les seconds ans
parce qu'il est possible que pour un
parent prend des heures du travail sont
juste
des filles ou moins pour ce tournoi et
on va revenir sur fear ou après mais là
on attend les derniers kocaman c'est
quand même la partie du jour là bas j'ai
pas j'ai pas le coup de famille alors
c'est toujours un écart de réfléchir au
bac comme bien de quoi quoi deux
couteaux mais c'est la partie sera
probablement fini dans deux coups en
fait dit on va pas durer deux trois
heures
joli quand même le bk tu n'as qu'à en
fait bah ils se sont jouées si souvent
plus d'interviews connais quoi peut-être
fc qui aux fans qui va bouger un truc
enfants papa voir pas se voir
possiblement possible
dans tous les cas 24 aeio voulu vous
montrer sorte un mois je vous fais sur
des cats et aux quatre à quinze jours et
ses essais et ses dépôts qui fait la
bonne affaire en fait avec sa petite
ville tranquille contre ou entre ding
métadier tout de suite ça l'est devenu
le tout de suite
quand elle joue ça enfin quand je joue
ça ça veut dire que tu a analysé un
petit peu cette variante à 100
ou et analysé parce que moi je suis dit
ok il a peut-être une petite idée ou
quelque chose mais ding il avait déjà
joué plusieurs parties
j'étais complètement
au bond et d'ailleurs je pense qu est-ce
qu on soutient pas forcément le h1 mais
là il fait une partie on mérite d'être
pour lui enfin entre celle là est celle
d'ailleurs toutes ces parties ou blanc
il pousse bien donc intéressant
mais ouais on soutient à soissons
bat j'ai un seul intérêt je ne gagne pas
quillot a d'ailleurs deux camps mais
pour gagner n'est pas et un deuxième tir
et que quelqu'un se qualifie qui y voit
tellement capable de battre
car ce
n'est pas le pense pas je pense que le
deuxième sera la même démonstration
de qui a les couilles haut et qu'il n'a
pas quoi donc
et comme fabien on n'a pas perdu le
match on s'est donné sans
fabiano il jouait mieux il ya trois ans
que maintenant c'est vrai mais de toute
manière je suis sur un cane simple
nippone comme ça comment toutefois je
pense que de carlson de toute façon
de toute façon c'est trop dur
dommage car elle n'a pas gagné contre 1
dans son 12e match notamment bien sûr
trop trop
s'était pas les villages
d'accord mais il a perdu une fois qu'il
a perdue avec
il gagne pas la premier liga n'est pas
la première partie décisive qu'il allait
perdre le match non ça va oui
mais quand même jusqu'à ce moment-là il
jouait quand même pas mal oui ça bien
sûr on regarde s'il famille perd la
première contre 47,5
fin du match aussi ils perdent et
peut-être encore plus que je pense pas
que c'est la fin du mois pour tout le
monde
devant
être fabien noise
il a besoin
alors après aujourd'hui amer à la
huitième ronde donc une nous restera six
ans on s'approche le format ça
s'approche la vente donc ouais et puis
on voit qu'il ya certains joueurs qui
peuvent battre n'est pas d'autres
peuvent pas en fait où es tu toi quand
tu vois les parties de jean-christophe
c'est
et enfin c'est ouais c'est après on peut
comprendre que
mais là par rapport à icare honey pot
ces intouchables en panne ils peuvent
pas les battre c'est une autre dans ce
tournoi c'est notre livre
dans ce tournoi et à ce moment là au
début du tournoi s'était il a presque
battu caruana
mais maintenant à ce moment précis du
tournoi il pourrait plus fort et plus
jouer comme ça avec tant d'assurance et
je tourne plutôt d'un petit bout d'os
est vite fait et ce que doux d'asphalté
nathan est ce que duda oui
ça fait mater tous rachats
fc auch
f5 one ok jolie absente quand même oui
mise bas parce que pions pro f6 joli
coup sur le coup interdit la tourache 7
il joue sur une feuille qui rend nos
pions en quatre pour que le courrier
blanc est le cavalier peut pas si rien
n'est sûr je sens que par quatre
au kef cinq jolies quand même bien sûr
bon croisiens qui a quand même l'air
selon le plan il ya quand même des
pièces
il veut pourquoi pas tout rejet sont là
c'est pour la tactique soit je sais pas
mais peut-être tour je trouve à tous
et non
pour h3 tu veux dire non non tour je
sais tu as ef d'hommes 6,6 sur man with
the post champions et puis le communisme
ok il a joué b4 ici voilà mais là c'est
pas
c'est bizarre aussi bekkat
qu'il ya peut-être pas de match direct
donc ouais
ok si seb
et moi
je suis sur m6 gagne aussi
donc oui f
-plusieurs
[Rires]
pas mal d'humour
tout le monde après moi je vais fans je
les aime beaucoup tous les deux je
m'entends très bien avec tous les deux
mais là c'est jay d'avoir des partis
comme sa déposition pareil ouais
ça fait mal
elle rapporte il n'a pas joué très fort
là il a pris un cadeau et c'est gergorin
il a juste pris un énorme cadeau
s'arrêtèrent pas une sonata magistrat
ok donc ça va être mat et hikaru qui
continue à réfléchir c'est ça ça jouer
à temps bon là ça bouge pas ça continue
on reviendra à la fin sur ali reza
h5 ça a joué ça jouer à 4 d'accord
intéressant
mais casse la structure
un peu bizarre de pas jouer il faut
prendre quatre échecs mais ok crise
prises et h4
hockey dacquois une chose découvert il
fut aux îles bureau
plutôt gagné l'opium à 6 que quatre
banques à peut-être que je m'en fous ces
six l'église et aura comme le piment
bouge pas sur vos tombes il a faibli
maximum la position après
34 ça avait l'air très très fort mais
bon
ouais mais alors faut 8 on sait que ça
gagnait fortement baissé gagné fortement
gagne fortement quand même
fortement ah oui on a démontré cette
vente alors bizarre quand même pas si
facile tu peut louper
loupe est bon
on a pensé que vous prend et cavaliers
france est elle plus simple après
l'affaiblissement mais non mais ce qu'il
a fait techniquement il joue bizarre
mas pignou tard mais peut-être mais
peut-être que c'est très bien
mais auquel a dû coup h 5 h 4 ça fait
sens il a besoin de contre je crois non
il va faire j'espère qu'à clémente il
est même dans ce qu'ils voient sur fous
ces six jeux sauf qu
elle pense que ça va pas marcher au
niveau tactique faut 3 et plus tard
en fanfare est
africain ça va pas marcher au niveau
tactique alger 5 et 6
mais bon il va être obligé c'est mon
principe est à 1% ses pions
ça va être fini c'est au cut ou g6
ok
il tente quoi
c'est sûr que c'est pas c'est pas bon 1
c'est sûr que c'est pas suffisant il a
fait trois
bons ils vu offert la même chose ça ne
rajoute un sou et surtout rinne celle ci
s'il veut bouger 5-fu proches que
beaucoup n'ont pas d'emploi parce
cavaliers jeu que
six
et un d'accord
peut-être qu'il va neiger quatre tours
aussi c'est fou
j'ai 5 roger
compliqué je ne sais pas j'ai pas
de régis me paraît normal et je voudrais
bien voir exclu cette heroes vient
écarter après fou des cas très dur à
dire un peu d'interviews jamais gagné ce
puits way la tête à deux cents mètres
sosa tour sera un lieu où surgit 4 il
paie un joueur comme ça et après m'être
un tour sur à singer juste fait des
coups comme ça mais voilà c'est ça son
plan ne pas gagner l'eau ils veulent et
c'est avec son four détroit toute la
partie en fait c'est un pur génie l ue
plus grande tout le temps voilà
fantastique oui dans ce cas l'air bien
sûr si va gagner comme ça joli et lyon
la partie voir entrer dans tous les
secteurs parce que c'est beau de 5 après
fou je gratte à tour en tour à cinq
jolies
et du coup c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il
doit jouer il doit tenter un truc comme
ça
tentez
donc à laurent fou non elle est à
nouveau de l'héroïne torah en il ya cinq
veaux 3-6 tour à halle en il ya 2 6
juillet at war direct action
il peut être un peu chatouilleux kompa
h36 que les astros à tour et faons si je
te retrouves à tout coup
à
saisir et
jouer comme ça comme ça
mais bon ok nombre
du délire là mais il va jouer tous
réussissent de toute façon fabi il
s'attendre à tout refi 6 1
mais tout arrive cinq ça permet de
continuer la partie
say to russia qu'il faut pour surfer 2,1
à voix à 5 c'est ça précisons
pour éviter donc le plan blanc essaie de
mettre les nîmois de simplifier le
nombre des pions
ouais surtout que c'est un pion faible
contre un pion assez fort oui si on
arrive à échanger a confirmé rick mercer
après tours f5 il va revenir sur fouet
aux copains
jusque là j'ai atteint qu'avec un autre
tour parce que la tape it gets 5
août à du g5 nantes au pitch est simple
on ça je veux faire de la corse un gpu
de doutre 2
le fossé 6 au 15 jours
comme ça j'utilise salaires et nous fait
que je jouais tours 5 surtout si je joue
tout réussit
elle 7,6 pour cette petite
[Musique]
et surtout un 4 x 4 4 se joue à l'orage
tour surgissent de zidrou tour je dis
oui
ouais bah il a encore un peu de boulot
faby trouve top 5
encore un tout petit peu de boulot
écoutez moi je me dis je me disais
toujours réussit à jouer une ligne juste
avant les candidats qui ont connu des
jeunes au juste pas c'est bizarre qui
est donc richard gagné
bekkat il a juste prix
ouais et cavaliers aux quatre roues je
dis n'importe quoi je ne sais pas trop
si j'ai les coûts
ont surgi au total cinq hommes et tu
peux lille à peut-être joué quatre
possibles
february2010 porte quoi je crois qu'il
m'a dit ok c'est bon on sait pas on n'a
pas
cavalier e 4 jouer vraiment
il a plutôt joué bref 5 alors c'est
bizarre d'abandonner après
donc je sais que les os 4 ça peut
intéresser même chose à sa ce bout non
mais c'est bizarre de jouer qui va dire
que maintenant je vais dire dame à
chaque tour je sais
on peut pas jouer
au
hockey bon ok peu importe tout tous
gagnants
et tu veux dire que ici il ya même plus
de temps à ya plus de tours g7 à ses
côtés à tora je suis témoin tous rêvent
de
suite
non la sematra
on va voir tous rêvent de quoi ok c'est
tout à fait c'est complètement gagnant
donc on va pas
là ça tourne encore abbas est toujours
la même position 1,1 g
quand on a il a joué des quatre
finalement
il a réussi à trouver son moment
[Musique]
on se demande par contre est-ce qu'il
ait réussi 10 4 millions moment
parce que pour des quatre peut-être
ne tourne pas très rond
attendant nous demande d'expliquer qu'il
valait 1 4 le problème c'est que tous
tous gagnants ont fait y ait trop si
vous regardez la position qu'a valeo 4
c'est pour eux que je pense que d'avoir
5 du jeu celle ci ajoute total cinq
tours je sais encore à dhamar 5 le tour
je sais est donc un peu comme chico est
cette tour hebdo et planning
pour ça ils ouvrent les colons est un
moyen bien sûr ce n'était pas plus que
tout c'est pas obligatoire comment dire
si vous regardez la périphérie quoi il
ya tout moi j'imagine que
même ça c'est bien enfin tout est bien
en fait
vous qui dans ces cas là y'a qu'a choisi
chacun choisit vous avez le roi qui est
tout seul face à
trois pièces lourdes puis changez
[Musique]
donc cavalier ou quatre noms c'est pas
un double brillant c'est un coût qui
gagne comme comme les autres
et à mi raisin n'est pas sûr qu'il ait
joué qu'il ait trouvé le momentum pour
jouer des quatre
des quinze la wii quand même parce qu'en
plus maintenant il ya dieu décédé dans
prendre b4
donc si on est obligé de prendre avec
une pièce
peut-être dam des deux
si on est obligé de prendre avec une
pièce bon ce truc notre structure est
certainement pourquoi est-ce que des
quatre et on a besoin d'eux ouais bah ça
a été jouée en 2004 difficile
difficile là je pense qu'ils aillent là
pas davantage
oui mais si tu fais dame prend des
quatre c'est pareil déjà on n'est pas
obligé de prendre mais même la finale
elle doit être ok moi
en gros il faut
se souvenir de paix des explications de
et il ya
à peu près deux heures